Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. As the enemy raced up the slope, Harold Hardrada tightened his grip on his sword hilt and whispered one last prayer. There was nothing for it now, he thought, but to die with honor. He had formed his men into a tight circle, linking their shields around the raven banner, where he and Tostick stood with his friends and captains. The Saxons, Harold thought, would have to cut their way through the line.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。随着敌人冲上山坡，哈罗德·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）握紧了剑柄，做完了最后一次祈祷。他心想，事到如今，唯有荣耀战死。他将手下排成一个紧密的圆阵，将盾牌连在雷鸦旗帜周围，他和托斯蒂格（Tostig）以及他的朋友和队长们就站在阵中。哈罗德心想，撒克逊人只能杀出一条血路。
He would make them pay in blood before the day was out. The enemy was screaming out their war songs. Through the dust and chaos he could see Harold Godwinson at the foot of the slope, urging his men on. The circle was shrinking. Harold's men were tiring, their shield arms heavy, their sword blows weary. And still the Saxons came on, eager to finish it. For just a moment, Harold thought of that
在大限到来之前，他要让敌人付出血的代价。敌人士气高昂，高唱着战歌。透过尘土与混乱，他看到哈罗德·戈德温逊（Harold Godwinson）正站在山坡脚下，催促着他的手下。圆阵正在缩小。哈罗德的手下们疲惫不堪，举盾的手臂沉重，挥剑的动作迟缓。然而撒克逊人依然蜂拥而上，急于了结此战。有那么一瞬间，哈罗德想起了那个
morning by the stream when he was little, when Olaf had asked him what he most wanted in life. House-calls! So many house-calls that they would eat all half-danced cows at single feast. What he wouldn't give for more Housecarls now. So there Dominic, the epic tones of Snorri Sturluson, the 13th century historian and poet from Iceland, one of the greatest writers in medieval history, whose epic account, the saga of King Harold is the definitive definitive, in fact pretty much the only account we have of the Battle of Stamford Bridge, and since today's episode is about the Battle of Stamford Bridge, I mean what else could we possibly have begun with but that great work by Snorri Sturluson? I mean really the only choice, except perhaps for a new version, a new account of the battle of Stanford Bridge.
清晨，在小溪旁，当他还是个孩子的时候，奥拉夫（Olaf）问他一生中最想要什么。家访！如此多的家访，以至于他们会在一次宴会上吃光所有半跳舞的母牛。为了现在能有更多的皇家近卫军（Housecarls），他什么都愿意付出。多米尼克，这是斯诺里·斯图鲁松（Snorri Sturluson）——这位来自冰岛的13世纪历史学家和诗人的史诗基调，他是中世纪历史上最伟大的作家之一，他那部史诗般的著作《哈罗德国王萨迦》（The Saga of King Harold）是关于斯坦福桥战役（Battle of Stamford Bridge）的权威著作，事实上，几乎是我们拥有的唯一记载。既然今天的节目是关于斯坦福桥战役的，我的意思是，除了斯诺里·斯图鲁松的那部伟大作品，我们还能以什么开场呢？这绝对是唯一的选择，也许除了一个新版本、对斯坦福桥战役的一个新记载之外。
Because actually that wasn't by Sonari Sturluson at all, was it? It was by you! It was, yeah. It's a forensic reconstruction, I think it's fair to say, of what happened at that battle in Adventures in Time Fury of the Vikings. So that is literally exactly what Harold Hardrada thought. He thought back to that moment when he was a little boy, which listeners will remember from the Harold Hardrada series and you know, the enemy was singing their war songs and he could see Harold Godwinson coming on and that's exactly what happened, Tom. Because do you know Dominic, when we're going to go on and do the Battle of Hastings and initially I put a passage from
因为事实上那根本不是斯诺里·斯图鲁松写的，对吧？那是你写的！是的，没错。我觉得可以公平地说，那是对《时空历险：维京人的愤怒》（Adventures in Time Fury of the Vikings）中那场战役经过的法医级别的重构。所以这字面意思上就是哈罗德·哈德拉达当时的想法。他回想起自己还是个小男孩时的那一刻，听众们会从哈罗德·哈德拉达系列节目中记起这一点，你知道的，敌人唱着战歌，他能看到哈罗德·戈德温逊逼近，这正是当时发生的事情，汤姆。因为你知道吗，多米尼克，当我们接下来要做黑斯廷斯战役（Battle of Hastings）时，我最初放了一段来自
Millennium, my book about which includes the account of the battle of Hastings. And initially I put a passage from Millennium, my book about, which includes the account of the battle of Hastings in the front. And then I thought, no, I shouldn't do that. I mean, you know, there are so many other epic accounts that were written at the time I put them in and I did think, I wonder whether Dominic will include his account in preference to that of Snorri Sturluson, the great writer. Yeah. And you sent me the text and you had done and I salute you.
《千禧年》（Millennium）——我的那本书里包含对黑斯廷斯战役的记述。最初我在前言里放了一段来自《千禧年》（我的那部包含黑斯廷斯战役记述的书）的文字。然后我想，不，我不应该那样做。我的意思是，你知道的，当时有那么多其他史诗般的记载被写了下来，我把它们放了进去，我确实在想，多米尼克会不会在那些记载中更倾向于采用伟大作家斯诺里·斯图鲁松的记述呢？是的。然后你把文本发给了我，你确实这么做了，我向你致敬。
This speaks to your fundamental lack of self-confidence, I think Tom. I think that is probably what it does, yeah. Whereas I'm not burdened by the same doubts and anxieties. No, you have the spirit of a Viking. I have the spirit of a cringing monk. I think there is, I don't think there's any doubt about that. By the way, please clip that and use that as a social media. So Dominic, I mean, today looking at one of the most exciting stories in all of medieval history and it's really the last great battle between Anglo-Saxons and Vikings for the throne of England. And I guess this is the battle with which so many accounts of the story of
这说明你骨子里缺乏自信，汤姆。我想这大概就是它所说明的吧，是的。而我则没有背负同样的怀疑和焦虑。不，你有一种维京人的精神。我有一种卑躬屈膝的僧侣的精神。我想，对此毫无疑问。顺便说一句，请把这段剪辑下来，把它当作社交媒体素材。所以，多米尼克，我的意思是，今天我们要探讨中世纪历史上最扣人心弦的故事之一，这确实是盎格鲁-撒克逊人和维京人为争夺英格兰王位而进行的最后一场大战。我想这也是许多关于
the Vikings finishes, doesn't it? In almost every general English language history of the Vikings, this is the last chapter. There may be a sort of epilogue, au revoir, farewell to the Viking age, but this is the last great narrative set piece. And you can see why, because although there are, as we'll discuss, there are subsequent attempts by Scandinavians to raid or indeed invade England. This is the last great one.
维京人故事的记载所结束的战役，不是吗？在几乎所有关于维京人的英文通史中，这就是最后一章。可能还有一个某种形式的后记，告别维京时代，但这就是最后一个宏大的叙事高潮。你能理解为什么，因为尽管正如我们将要讨论的，后来北欧人仍有试图袭扰甚至入侵英格兰的举动。但这确实是最后一次大战。
It's the one that comes closest. And it has, it really does have the quality of myth because at its heart are two irresistible, colorful, doomed characters, Harold Hardrada and Harold Godwinson. And both of them stand for things greater than themselves, i.e. a civilization, Anglo-Saxon England, as you put it, what, meatballs and mustaches. Yeah, and the Vikings, dragon ships and booming laughs. And booming laughs, exactly.
这是最接近成功的一次。它确实具有神话般的特质，因为它的核心是两个不可抗拒、色彩鲜明、注定悲剧的人物，哈罗德·哈德拉达和哈罗德·戈德温逊。他们两人都代表着比自身更宏大的事物，即一种文明——正如你所说，盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰，肉丸和胡须。是的，还有维京人，龙船和宏亮的笑声。还有宏亮的笑声，完全正确。
So let us start with the man at the centre of the story, Harald Hardrada, who we talked about last week. So last week we left him as King of Norway. The beginning of 1066, he's probably 50 years old. So he's the oldest of the contenders in this story. He's had the most extraordinary life. A lot of what we talked about last week, you know, was in that sort of fuzzy area between myth and history and fiction.
那么让我们从故事中心的那个人开始，哈罗德·哈德拉达，我们上周谈过他。所以上周我们离开他时，他是挪威国王。1066年伊始，他大概50岁了。所以他是这个故事中所有竞争者中年纪最大的一位。他经历了极其非凡的一生。我们上周谈到的很多内容，你知道的，都处于神话、历史和虚构之间的那种模糊地带。
But we know that, you know, he was exiled as a teenager. He went off to be a mercenary in Kievan Rus, he was a Varangian guard, messing around with the emperor and the empress, possible eye gouging, comes back, snakes, great scenes, becomes king of Norway. And we ended the Harald Hardrada series talking about how he earns the reputation Hardrada. So there's a kind of chilling ruthlessness to Harold Hardrada. Adam of Braemann, who we've mentioned before, called him the Thunderbolt of the North. William of Poitiers, who we mentioned, William's chaplain, on Monday said he was the strongest living man under the sun. So even if you strip away the inventions
但我们知道，你知道的，他在十几岁时被流放。他去基辅罗斯当了雇佣兵，他曾是瓦兰吉亚卫队（Varangian guard）的成员，与皇帝和皇后纠缠不清，可能还经历过挖眼酷刑，然后回国，带着蛇，经历过宏大的场面，成为了挪威国王。我们在哈罗德·哈德拉达系列节目的结尾谈到了他是如何赢得“哈德拉达”（Hardrada，意为严酷者）这个绰号的。因此哈罗德·哈德拉达身上有一种令人毛骨悚然的冷酷无情。我们之前提到过的不来梅的亚当（Adam of Braemann）称他为“北方霹雳”。我们提到过的普瓦捷的威廉（William of Poitiers，威廉国王的随军牧师）在周一说他是“太阳底下最强壮的活人”。所以，即使你剥离掉
of the sagas, Harold Hardrada is a frighteningly ruthless, vengeful, effective, avaricious, impressive man. He is the distillation of the Viking ethos, I think. And that's why his story makes such a wonderful conclusion to any history of the Vikings. And it's why he's such a perfect history for a saga of the kind that Snorri Sturluson and the other Icelandic writers have. And one of the things that's fascinating about this particular episode is that we have a kind of first draft of history in the form of the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle. Yes, we do. So we talked about Tostig in the previous episode and the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle tells
萨迦传说中的虚构成分，哈罗德·哈德拉达也是一个令人感到可怕的冷酷、善报复、高效、贪婪且令人印象深刻的人。我认为他是维京人精神的精髓。这就是为什么他的故事能为任何维京人历史写下一个如此精彩的结局。这也是为什么他能成为像斯诺里·斯图鲁松和其他冰岛作家所写的那种萨迦的完美历史主角。这个特定剧集最迷人的一点在于，我们拥有《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》（Anglo-Saxon Chronicle）形式的历史初稿。是的，我们确实有。我们在上一集中谈到了托斯蒂格，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》告诉
us that he has retreated from England in 1065, that he's gone to Flanders, that he then launches a raid on the Isle of Wight, that he then launches a raid on the Humber and that he then goes to Scotland. And that is all it tells us. But the thing that about Snorri's epic is that it fills in a lot of those details, whether accurately or not is up for debate, but certainly in a much more dramatic manner. So let's, if we were doing this as an HBO series, we would start this episode with Harold in his hall in Vikken, which is near basically the Oslo region in Norway, and his days of war appear to be over.
我们他在1065年从英格兰撤退，他去了法兰德斯，然后他对怀特岛（Isle of Wight）发起了袭扰，接着对亨伯河（Humber）发起了袭扰，随后又去了苏格兰。这就是它告诉我们的全部内容。但斯诺里的史诗的神奇之处在于，它补充了许多这样的细节，至于是否准确还有待商榷，但无疑是以一种更加戏剧化的方式呈现的。所以让我们想象一下，如果我们把这拍成一部HBO剧集，我们会以哈罗德在维肯（Vikken，基本上靠近挪威奥斯陆地区）的大厅里的场景作为本集的开端，他那充满战争的日子似乎已经结束了。
He's fought this interminable war with the Danes that has basically ended in a stalemate. You can sort of see how you would shoot the scene. He's sitting there at the end of his hall, grizzled. The old wolf. The old wolf, exactly. And one day in the summer of 1066, I mean, this must have been effectively what happened. A man walks into his hall, a man the sagas describe as, quote, a tall tall strong man, a big talker and warlike with an enormous English moustache. I mean, the thing that's interesting about that description is that in the life of Edward the Confessor, which was commissioned by Tostig's sister, he's described as being short. So interesting contradiction there. Maybe his sister didn't
他与丹麦人进行了这场旷日持久的战争，基本以僵局告终。你大概能想象出这个场景会如何拍摄。他饱经风霜地坐在大厅的尽头。老狼。老狼，没错。1066年夏天的某一天，我的意思是，这基本上一定就是当时发生的事。一个男人走进了他的大厅，萨迦传说将这个男人描述为：“一个身材高大强壮的男子，健谈且好战，留着巨大的英格兰胡须。”我的意思是，关于这个描述有趣的一点是，在由托斯蒂格的姐姐委托撰写的《忏悔者爱德华生平》（Life of Edward the Confessor）中，他被描述为个子矮小。所以这里有一个有趣的矛盾。也许他姐姐并不
know what she was talking about. Maybe I'm going with the sagas, Tom. I'm always, by the way, in this episode, going to go with the sagas. So this is Tostig. And as we described last time, Tostig is seething with resentment against his brother, Harold Godwinson, who he blames for his exile from England, the fact that Moorcar has become Earl of Northumbria, that everybody hates him, all of this. Now, Tostig in the last episode had been raiding England, described him messing around in the Isle of Wight and the Humber and whatnot. But I think it's pretty clear that after he's gone off to Scotland and he's been blown around, he's looking for something more than raiding. I mean, by going
知道自己在说什么。汤姆，我打算选择相信萨迦传说。我顺便说一句，在本集中我总是会选择相信萨迦传说。这就是托斯蒂格。正如我们上次所描述的，托斯蒂格对他的哥哥哈罗德·戈德温逊充满了怨恨，他将自己被驱逐出英格兰、莫卡（Moorcar）成为诺森布里亚伯爵（Earl of Northumbria）以及所有人讨厌他这一切都归咎于哥哥。现在，托斯蒂格在上一集中一直在袭扰英格兰，传说中他在怀特岛和亨伯河等地瞎折腾。但我认为很明显，在他前往苏格兰并在那里饱受风吹雨打之后，他所追求的不仅仅是袭扰。我的意思是，通过去
to get help, he is signing up effectively to regime change in England. It's clear to him his brother's never going to take him back. There's no possibility of a rapprochement. Now if the sagas are to be believed, Harald Hardrada is not Tostig's first choice because the sagas say initially he goes to see somebody you mentioned very briefly last time, Svein of Denmark. And Tostig in the sagas says to him, why don't you come with me and win the country, win England as Cnut your mother's brother did. And I think this has the ring of absolute plausibility. Svein says, no, I'm not Cnut. I don't have Cnut's capabilities. Only with difficulty can I defend my own Danish dominions against the Northmen, against the Norwegians,
寻求援助，他实际上是在参与英格兰的政权更迭。他很清楚他的哥哥永远不会收留他，双方已经没有和解的可能。现在，如果相信萨迦传说的说法，哈罗德·哈德拉达并不是托斯蒂格的第一选择，因为萨迦传说称，他最初去见了你在上集非常简短地提到过的人——丹麦的斯韦恩（Svein of Denmark）。萨迦传说中的托斯蒂格对他说：“你为什么不跟我一起来征服这个国家，像你母亲的兄弟克努特（Cnut）那样赢得英格兰呢？”我认为这听起来绝对合乎情理。斯韦恩说：“不，我不是克努特。我没有克努特的能力。我竭尽全力也只能勉强保卫我自己的丹麦领地不受北方人、挪威人的侵扰，”
which is absolutely accurate. Had Svein taken Tostig up on his offer and gone to England, there's no doubt in my mind that Harald Hardrada would have immediately invaded and conquered Denmark. So Svein would have been bonkers to take that up. Tostig, we're told, reacted contemptuously. He says, I expected more if so gallant a man, and I will look for help, he says, from a king who isn't frightened of a great enterprise as you are. It has to be said that both the contemporaneous sources and the sagas imply that Tostick does not have great interpersonal skills. That's absolutely true.
这绝对是事实。如果斯韦恩接受了托斯蒂格的提议并前往英格兰，我坚信哈罗德·哈德拉达会立即入侵并征服丹麦。所以斯韦恩如果接受了那才真是疯了。我们得知，托斯蒂格对此反应轻蔑。他说：“我对一个如此勇敢的人抱有更高的期望，我要去找一个像你一样不畏惧宏伟事业的国王寻求帮助。”必须说明的是，无论是同时代的资料还是萨迦传说都暗示，托斯蒂格并不具备出色的为人处世技巧。这绝对是真的。
He's not a charmer. And to be fair, the record of history suggests that everybody despises Tostick. Yeah. But Tom. Tostick will redeem himself at the end of this episode and behave, I think, in a very impressive and gallant way. So now Tostick crosses the Skagorak to Vikkun and he finds Harold Hardrada in his hall. Now at first, Harold Hardrada too is dubious. You talked last time about how some of William of Normandy's advisors said, England really?
他不是一个有个人魅力的人。平心而论，历史记录表明所有人都鄙视托斯蒂格。是的。但汤姆，托斯蒂格在本集结束时会自我救赎，我认为他的行为将非常令人印象深刻且英勇。现在托斯蒂格穿过斯卡格拉克海峡（Skagerrak）来到维肯（Vikkun），在哈罗德·哈德拉达的大厅里找到了他。起初，哈罗德·哈德拉达对他也持怀疑态度。你上周谈到诺曼底威廉（William of Normandy）的一些谋士是如何说的：“英格兰？真的吗？”
That is a tough nut to crack. That is a hell of a gamble. And Hardrada hesitates. We're told, the king replied that the North men had no great desire for a campaign in England. People say that the English are not to be trusted. Who says that? You're the one that says that. Outrageous. Everyone knows that an Englishman's word is his body.
那可是一块难啃的骨头。那是一场天大的豪赌。哈德拉达犹豫了。我们得知，国王回答说北方人对远征英格兰并没有多大兴趣。人们说英格兰人不可信。谁说的？这话是你说的。太离谱了。人人都知道英格兰人的话就像他们的身体一样算数。
This is fools in Norway. Idiots. Remember, Harold Hardrada has never been to England, so he knows not whereof he Everyone knows that an Englishman's word is his body. Right. This is fools in Norway. Yeah. Idiots. Remember, Harald Hardrada has never been to England, so he knows not whereof he speaks. Yeah, true. And Tostik says, hold on. Remember you have a claim to the English throne. He reminds Hardrada that a quarter of a century earlier during the succession crisis after the death of Cnut. There was this story that half of Cnut and Hardrada's brother, Magnus, had done a deal that whichever of them died without an heir would inherit
这真是挪威的傻瓜。白痴。记住，哈罗德·哈德拉达从未去过英格兰，所以他根本不知道自己在人人都知道英格兰人的话就像他们的身体一样算数。没错。这真是挪威的傻瓜。是的。白痴。记住，哈罗德·哈德拉达从未去过英格兰，所以他根本不知道自己在谈论什么。是的，没错。托斯蒂格说：“等等。记住你对英格兰王位有继承权。”他提醒哈德拉达，四分之一世纪前，在克努特死后的王位继承危机期间，
the other's kingdom, all of his kingdoms. And Tostick says to Hardrada, Magnus was your brother and you've inherited that claim. Edward the confessor has died without an heir. And under the terms of that deal, England is yours. Now, whether they'd really made that deal, it's not written down anywhere, so who knows, but it's convenient for Hardrada. And Tostick goes on, according to the sagas, if you want it, England is yours. I can talk most of the lords there to supporting you. That, as we know, is a dubious claim to say the least.
曾有这样一个传言：克努特和哈德拉达的哥哥马格努斯（Magnus）曾达成一项协议，无论他们俩谁在没有继承人的情况下死去，都将继承对方的王国，即他所有的王国。托斯蒂格对哈德拉达说：“马格努斯是你的哥哥，你继承了那一主张。忏悔者爱德华（Edward the Confessor）死后没有留下继承人。根据那项协议的条款，英格兰是属于你的。”现在，他们是否真的达成过那个协议，任何地方都没有文字记录，所以谁知道呢，但这对外哈德拉达来说很便利。据萨迦传说记载，托斯蒂格接着说：“如果你想要，英格兰就是你的。我可以劝说那里的绝大多数领主支持你。”正如我们所知，这是一个大打折扣的说法，至少可以说是可疑的。
Tostik goes on and he appeals to Hodrad as vanity. Everybody says that never in all the Northlands has there been a warrior king to compare with you. So it seems odd to me that you spent 15 years trying to conquer Denmark and yet you shrink from the chance of ruling England when it is yours for the taking. Oh he's subtle there isn't he? Now the sagas then say that Harold and Tostig talked long and frequently together, which undoubtedly they must have done. And Harold has to weigh this up, right, because this is a
托斯蒂格继续迎合哈德拉达的虚荣心。每个人都说，整个北方从未有过一个战王能与你相比。所以在我看来，你花了15年时间试图征服丹麦，却在英格兰唾手可得时怯于统治它，这不是很奇怪吗？他在这里真是委婉含蓄，不是吗？萨迦传说接着说，哈罗德和托斯蒂格进行了长时间且频繁的交谈，毫无疑问他们一定这么做了。哈罗德必须权衡利弊，对吧，因为这是一场
gamble. Now until this moment he has never shown the slightest interest in England and people who listen to our Harold Hardrada two-parter will know that basically all his career was spent in the East, not the West. He's always looked East. Because there are two paths to wealth in the Viking world out there, England or Constantinople basically by this point. So this is a novelty for him. He's never really thought about England before. Some of his chief advisors we're told said, look, you can do anything. You're the Thunderbolt of the North. Why not? Let's go for it. Others, and this echoes again,
赌博。直到这一刻，他对英格兰从未表现出丝毫兴趣，听过我们哈罗德·哈德拉达上下两集的听众会知道，他的整个职业生涯基本上都是在东方度过的，而不是西方。他一直将目光投向东方。因为在这个时期的维京世界里，通往财富的道路基本上只有两条：要么去英格兰，要么去君士坦丁堡。所以这对他是件新鲜事。他以前从未真正考虑过英格兰。我们得知他的一些核心谋士说：“看，你无所不能。你是北方霹雳。为什么不呢？干吧！”其他人则——这再次呼应了
what the Normans said to William, others again said that England was difficult to attack, that it was very full of people, and that the men-at-arms were so brave that one of them was better than two of Harold's best men, which actually, again, bears out what you were saying last time, that the English are generally underrated. We tend to think, oh, the English were rubbish because they were very peaceable, but actually, they're more formidable than you think. Yeah, and to look at it from the Viking point of view, Viking armies keep going over to England. They keep battering it, conquering it, draining it of its silver and still it endures and comes back kind of stronger than ever.
诺曼人对威廉说的话——另一些人说英格兰很难攻击，那里人口众多，而且军士们非常勇猛，其中一人能顶得上哈罗德手下两名最精锐的士兵。这实际上再次证实了你上次所说的话，即英格兰人普遍被低估了。我们往往认为，哦，英格兰人很逊，因为他们很爱好和平，但实际上，他们比你想象的要强大得多。是的，从维京人的角度来看，维京军队不断前往英格兰。他们不断重击英格兰，征服它，榨干它的白银，然而它依然挺立，并以某种方式变得更加强大。
Yeah, exactly. So Harold sits and thinks about it and eventually he decides he'll do it. And I think there are three reasons why. Number one is the great traditional Viking reason, which I think does then sort of cement his last Viking reputation. And that is basically money. He has had terrible trouble in Norway raising taxes to pay for his wars, hence the name Hardrada because he's basically been harrying people who won't pay their taxes. But England as we've established is very,
对，没错。所以哈罗德坐在那里思考了一会儿，最终他决定这么做。我认为原因有三。第一点是伟大的维京传统原因，我认为这确实巩固了他最后的维京人声誉。那就是——基本上是为了钱。他在挪威筹集税款来支付战争开销方面遇到了极大的麻烦，这也是他被称为“严酷者”的原因，因为他基本上一直在折腾那些不愿纳税的人。但正如我们已经确定的那样，英格兰非常、
very rich and even if he didn't get the crown, imagine that he lands, there's a lot of battles, there's a kind of stalemate, a little bit like it was with, you know, Svein Fortbeard and Cnut in the early days. He might just go home with loads of daengeld. The English would buy him off. The English would buy him off. So that's the, you know, that could be a worst case scenario. He doesn't think he's going to die. I mean, it's not the worst case scenario, actually, as it will turn out, is it? But yes, I mean, that's what he could get. Then I think there's a geopolitical reason. It's very clear that Harald has always wanted to, you know, Norway's not enough for him. Basically, if you're a Norwegian or Danish king, your ambition is obviously to try to be the next canute, to build a kind of North Sea empire. It would make complete sense that you might want to try to do that.
非常富有，即使他没有得到王位，想象一下他登陆了，经历了一场又一场大战，出现了一种僵局——有点像早期“胡须起义者”斯韦恩（Svein Forkbeard）和克努特（Cnut）那时的情况。他可能带着大笔丹麦金（danegeld）回家。英格兰人会花钱把他买通。英格兰人会花钱把他买通。所以这是，你知道的，这可能是最坏的情况。他不认为自己会死。我的名字叫——其实正如结果将证明的那样，这不是最坏的情况，对吧？但是的，我的意思是，这就是他可能得到的。然后我认为还有一个地缘政治原因。很明显，哈罗德一直想——你知道的，挪威对他的雄心来说还不够。基本上，如果你是挪威或丹麦国王，你的野心显然是努力成为下一个克努特，建立一个某种形式的北海帝国。你可能想要尝试这样做，这是完全合情合理的。
And I guess Harald Hardrada has seen Yaroslav the Wise, the great king of Kiev, and he's seen the emperor in Constantinople. So he has a sense perhaps that Norway is a slightly shrunken and impoverished stage compared to those. He's been playing for Real Madrid and now he's managing Burnley and he probably thinks to himself, ideally I'd be managing a bigger club. And the third thing I think is psychological. And there's no reason to doubt the evidence of the saga is that Harold Hardrada is a very restless warlike man who basically, he's a bit like Alexander the Great. He doesn't like building bridges and discussing tax returns. What he really
我想哈罗德·哈德拉达见识过基辅伟大的国王雅罗斯拉夫智者（Yaroslav the Wise），也见识过君士坦丁堡的皇帝。所以相比之下，他或许觉得挪威是一个有些萎缩且贫瘠的舞台。他以前一直在皇家马德里踢球，现在他在执教伯恩利（Burnley），他心里大概会想，理想情况下我应该执教一家更大的俱乐部。第三点我认为是心理因素。没有任何理由怀疑萨迦传说的证据，即哈罗德·哈德拉达是一个极度焦躁不安、爱好战争的人，基本上，他有点像亚历山大大帝。他不喜欢架桥和讨论纳税申报表。他真正
likes doing is fighting people. But also unlike Alexander the Great, he's now 50. So he's prone to a massive midlife crisis, I guess. Massive midlife crisis. Snorri says, he yearned to conquer new realms. And again, if you're doing this, it's your TV series. He's sitting there on his throne grizzled one last time. Will you join me? You know, that kind of thing. So the orders go out, they assemble a fleet in the Western fjords, we're told 200 long ships and 100 transports. So if you assume about 50 to 60 men per
喜欢做的事是跟人打仗。而且与亚历山大大帝不同的是，他现在已经50岁了。所以我想他很容易经历一场严重的中年危机。严重的中年危机。斯诺里说：“他渴望征服新的国度。”同样，如果你正在拍摄这部剧，这就是你的电视剧集。他最后一次饱经风霜地坐在王座上。“你愿意加入我吗？”诸如此类的情节。于是命令下达，他们在西部峡湾集结了一支舰队，我们被告知有200艘长船和100艘运输船。所以如果你假设每艘
longship, that would be about 10,000 men. That's plausible, because that's similar to the force that he threw against Denmark. It's actually bigger than the fleet that Cnut used to conquer England in 1016. And I guess that like William's invasion force, which is massing at this very moment on the North coast of France, Harold's name and reputation is a huge draw. Oh yeah. If you're a young man from Norway, Sweden, Denmark, or indeed the East or from Flanders or wherever it might be. And the word has gone out. Hardrada sails again. It's like something from a western, isn't it?
长船大约有50到60人，那大约就是1万人。这是合乎情理的，因为这类似于他用来对抗丹麦的兵力。这实际上比克努特在1016年用来征服英格兰的舰队还要大。我想，就像此刻正在法国北部海岸集结的威廉的入侵部队一样，哈罗德的名字和声誉具有巨大的吸引力。噢，是的。如果你是来自挪威、瑞典、丹麦，或是来自东方、法兰德斯或任何其他地方的年轻人。消息已经传出去了。哈德拉达再次扬帆起航了。这就像西部片里的情节，不是吗？
The dragon boats shall roareth last time. As the sun sets in the west. It's Theoden in the Lord of the Rings, right? One last time, you know, with all that stuff. So the fleet is assembled. Before leaving, he goes to visit the shrine of his late brother, Saint Olaf in a place called Nideros, which is today Trondheim. And Saint Olaf has already been turned into a slightly implausible patron saint of Norway as a way of buttressing the Hadradar dynasty regime. And he supposedly, I mean, why you would do this, God knows you'll know more about this than me Tom, he trims the hair and nails of the body of his brother and then bizarrely throws the key of the tomb into the river.
龙船将在最后一次夕阳西下时怒吼。这是《指环王》里的希奥登（Theoden），对吧？最后一次，你知道的，带着所有那些悲壮的情绪。于是舰队集结完毕。在离开之前，他去拜访了他已故的哥哥圣奥拉夫（Saint Olaf）的神社，地点在一个叫尼德罗斯（Nideros）的地方，也就是今天的特隆赫姆（Trondheim）。圣奥拉夫已经被塑造成了一个多少有些勉强的挪威主保圣人，以此来巩固哈德拉达王朝的统治。他据说——天知道为什么要这么做，汤姆，你对此会比我更了解——他修剪了他哥哥尸体的头发和指甲，然后匪夷所思地把坟墓的钥匙扔进了河里。
Well Otto III in the millennial year, the year 1000 had done the same for Charlemagne. He'd gone down into Charlemagne's tomb and trimmed his nails. Yeah. Right. So it's obviously a thing. Right. Now a very bad blow for Hardrada is that just as they're preparing to sail, his men are afflicted by a series of terrible dreams.
好吧，奥托三世（Otto III）在千禧年，即公元1000年时也对查理曼（Charlemagne）做过同样的事。他曾走入查理曼的陵墓并修剪了他的指甲。没错。所以这显然是一种习俗。没错。现在，对哈德拉达来说一个非常糟糕的打击是，就在他们准备起航时，他的手下遭遇了一系列可怕梦境的折磨。
And Tom, you may scoff at this, but I have no reason to doubt that this happened. So first of all, there's a man called Geerd, and he dreamed of seeing ravens perched on the prowess of all their longships and a sinister witch wife singing that all the men would soon be a feast for crows. That's not good, is it? Unfortunately, there's another bloke called Thord and he says, well, he's also had a dream. He saw two armies lined up for battle in the fields of England.
汤姆，你可能会对此嗤之以鼻，但我没有理由怀疑这没有发生过。首先，有一个叫杰德（Geerd）的人，他梦见乌鸦栖息在他们所有长船的船头上，还有一个不祥的巫婆在高唱，所有人很快就会成为乌鸦的盘中餐。这可不妙，对吧？不幸的是，还有另一个叫托德（Thord）的家伙，他说，好吧，他也做了一个梦。他看见两支军队在英格兰的原野上列阵作战。
Another of these witch wives riding between them on a wolf and I quote, the wolf had a man's carcass in his mouth and the blood was dripping from his jaws. And when he'd eaten one body, she, the witch wife, threw another corpse into his mouth until he swallowed them all. Again, it could be the English. But then unfortunately, the crowning dream, Harold himself has a dream that his brother Olaf, with his nails nicely trimmed, turns up during the night wearing the same armour that he had worn at the fatal battle of Stiklestad, which we
另一个巫婆骑着一匹狼穿梭在两军之间，我引用原话：“那匹狼嘴里叼着一具男人的尸体，鲜血从它的下巴上滴落。当它吃完一具尸体时，她——那个巫婆——又把另一具尸体扔进它嘴里，直到它把所有尸体都吞下肚。”同样，这可能是指英格兰人。但接着不幸的是，最顶级的梦境来了，哈罗德本人做了一个梦：他的哥哥奥拉夫——指甲修剪得很整洁——在夜间现身了，穿着他在致命的斯蒂克兰斯塔德战役（Battle of Stiklestad）中穿过的同一套盔甲，我们在哈罗德·哈德拉达系列节目中讲过那场战役。他在那里被砍成了碎片，不是吗？
did in our Harold Hardrada series. Where he's chopped to pieces, isn't he? Yeah. So Olaf, bleeding, turns up in this armor and sings to him, thy death is near, thy corpse I fear, the crow will feed, the witch wife's steed. So this is a bad, bad development for Harold Hardrada. You can imagine him shivering as he stands on the prow of his ship. Do you think he would shiver? He would shiver. He'd give a little imperceptible shiver, I think. An internal shiver. He'd
所以奥拉夫带着血迹穿着这套盔甲出现，并对他唱道：“死期近临汝莫留，尸骸难保终入喉，乌鸦饱食任贪求，巫婆坐骑乐悠悠。”这对哈罗德·哈德拉达来说是一个极其糟糕的发展。你可以想象他站在船头时浑身发抖的样子。你觉得他会发抖吗？他会发抖的。我想他会产生一丝几乎察觉不到的颤抖。内心的颤抖。他会把他的裸皮斗篷——你知道的，
draw his bare skin, you know, his wolf skin cloak tighter around him. He would gaze back at the dark forests of Norway and then his face would set and he would gaze at the grey steely waters of the North Sea and set sail for England. This is literally what happened. So August 1066, it's now or never they set sail. Now at first they seem to have headed northwest towards Orkney and Orkney is part of Harold's empire.
他的狼皮斗篷——在身上裹得更紧。他会回望挪威黑暗的森林，然后他的面部线条会紧绷起来，凝视着北海灰暗如钢铁般的海水，扬帆起航前往英格兰。这简直就是当时真实发生的事情。所以1066年8月，千载难逢的机会就在眼前，他们起航了。起初他们似乎是朝着西北方向的奥克尼群岛（Orkney）驶去，奥克尼是哈罗德帝国的一部分。
And we are told by Heimskringler, the King Harold saga, that there he collected more men and he left, the saga says he left Queen Elisife. So she's the one from Yaroslav's daughter. And her daughters, Maria and Ingegird in Orkney. But historians now think that's unlikely that she might have been dead by this point anyway. And that actually he had a second wife called Tora and that maybe it was her who he left in Orkney. Anyway, we don't need to worry about them. And it's interesting because there's a 12th century English chronicler, so that's well
《海姆斯金格拉》（Heimskringla，即《挪威王萨迦》）告诉我们，他在那里召集了更多的人，萨迦传说说他将伊莉丝芙王后（Queen Elisife，也就是雅罗斯拉夫的女儿）以及她的两个女儿玛丽亚（Maria）和英格吉德（Ingegird）留在了奥克尼。但历史学家现在认为这不太可能，因为她到这个时候可能无论如何都已经去世了。实际上他还有第二个妻子叫托拉（Tora），也许留在奥克尼的是她。总之，我们不需要为她们操心。有趣的是，有一位12世纪的英格兰编年史家——这远在斯诺里之前——说托斯蒂格整个夏天都和苏格兰国王马尔科姆（Malcolm）厮混在一起（据推测是在见完哈罗德·哈德拉达之后），他已经与来自奥克尼的船只汇合了，这些船只显然是哈罗德派去的。
before Snorri, who says that Tostig, who has spent the whole summer, presumably having come back from seeing Harold Hardrada hanging out with Malcolm of Scotland, that he has already been joined by ships from Orkney, presumably sent by Hardrada. Yeah, it's slightly confusing where Tostig is at this point because the sagas give different explanations but Tostig is definitely doing something up in Scotland. He's with Malcolm. I mean, that's what the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle says. So Harold now turns south, he sails down the east coast of Scotland towards the ancient
是的，托斯蒂格此时身在何处有些令人困惑，因为萨迦传说给出了不同的解释，但托斯蒂格绝对在苏格兰做着某些事。他和马尔科姆在一起。我的意思是，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》就是这么说的。于是哈罗德转向南方，他沿着苏格兰东海岸南下，驶向古代的诺森布里亚王国，当然，这部分英格兰拥有非常、非常深厚的斯堪的纳维亚根基和斯堪的纳维亚传统。9月中旬，哈罗德在海岸的一个地方登陆，当时被称为克利夫兰（Cliffland），也就是我们现在所说的北约克郡的克利夫兰（Cleveland）。这里是高度丹麦化的领土。所以他来到最初的几个村庄——它们今天已经是米德尔斯堡（Middlesbrough）的郊区，即奥姆斯比（Ormsby）、斯特恩斯比（Steinsby）、托尔斯比（Tolesby）。
kingdom of Northumbria, of course, the part of England with very, very strong Scandinavian roots and the Scandinavian traditions. And in the middle of September, Hardrada makes landfall on the coast at a place called then called Cliffland, what we would now call Cleveland, North Yorkshire. And this is very Danish territory. So the first villages that he comes to, which are now suburbs of Middlesbrough, today they are Ormsby, Steinsby, Tolesby. They are Danish names. They are named after Vikings called Orm, Steen, Tol.
这些都是丹麦语名字。它们是以名叫奥姆（Orm）、斯廷（Steen）、托尔（Tol）的维京人名字命名的。我们得知当地人没有对哈罗德进行抵抗。这也许是因为——换作你，你也不会抵抗的，对吧？你不会的。而且这也是那些可能与斯堪的纳维亚有贸易往来的地方，在那里，斯堪的纳维亚人的到来或许并不像他们如果在德文郡（Devon）登陆那样令人感到恐怖和怪异。所以他们在那里瞎折腾了一番。然后他们向南航行了40英里，来到一个叫做斯卡迪堡（Skardy's Fort, Skardaborg）的地方，
And the people that were told offered Hardrada no resistance. Now that may be, I mean, you wouldn't, would you? You wouldn't. But also these are places where they probably have trade with Scandinavia, where the arrival of Scandinavians is not maybe as terrifying and outlandish as it would be had they landed in Devon, let us say. So they do a bit of messing around there. Then they sail 40 miles south to a place called Skardy's Fort,
这个地方是以一个才华横溢名叫托吉尔·斯卡迪（Thorgyll Skadi）的人命名的，托吉尔是兔唇，而斯卡迪堡（Skardaborg）我们现在叫做斯卡布罗（Scarborough）。所以他们在斯卡布罗登陆了。现在斯卡布罗是一个较大的城镇，有防御工事，这里的居民显然感觉自己更像是英格兰人，因为他们确实试图抵抗哈罗德。哈罗德无论如何还是攻占了该镇，萨迦传说告诉我们：“北方人杀害了许多人，并夺取了他们所能触及的一切战利品。如今英格兰人若想保全性命，除了向哈罗德国王投降别无他法，因此他所到之处都征服了这个国家。”换句话说，他把斯卡布罗当作了一个反面典型。他洗劫并劫掠了这里，这向英格兰东北部的所有城镇传递了一个信息：
Skardaborg, which is named after a brilliant man called Thorgyll Skadi, Thorgyll's the hair lipped and Skardy's Fort, Skardaborg, we now call Skabra. So they land at Skabra. Now Skabra is a larger town, it's fortified and the people here clearly seem to have felt more English because they actually do try to resist Hardrada. Hardrada takes the town anyway and we're told by the saga, the Northmen killed many people there and took all the booty they could lay hold of. There was nothing left for the Englishmen now if they would preserve their lives but to submit to King Harold and thus he subdued the country wherever he came. So in other words, he's made an example of Scarborough. He has looted it, sacked it, and this sends a message to all the
你挡我的路，我就痛击你。但你对我和善，我也会对你以礼相待。完全正确。于是他转入亨伯河口，到这个时候，我们可以相当确定他已经与托斯蒂格会合了，托斯蒂格可能带了一些法兰德斯雇佣兵，并且他绝对拥有来自苏格兰马尔科姆国王的手下。
towns of Eastern Northeastern England. You stand in my way and I will hammer you. But you do right by me and I'll do right by you. Exactly. So now he turns into the mouth of the Humber and by this point, we can be pretty sure he has joined forces with Tostig and Tostig has some Flemish mercenaries probably, and he definitely has men from Scotland, from King Malcolm.
托斯蒂格在1066年这一年里已经顺着亨伯河向上航行过一次了，这提醒人们，如果你有任何斯堪的纳维亚入侵传统的话，亨伯河就是你首选的必经之路。它就像一把巨大的匕首直刺英格兰腹地的要害。这是一个标准的套路，对吧？这并不罕见。到目前为止，哈罗德一直在遵循许多维京人屡试不爽的作战手册。他此时可能拥有大约12,000名士兵。这包括他自己的儿子、托斯蒂格名叫斯库利（Skuli）的儿子。他们逆亨伯河而上，然后转入乌兹河（River Ouse）。人们还记得他们曾在现今俄罗斯和乌克兰的河流网中如何行事。现在他们在
Tostig has already sailed up the Humber once already this year of 1066 and it's a reminder of the way that for if you have any kind of Scandinavian inheritance of invasion, the Humber is where you go. It's like a great dagger pointed into the vitals of Middle England. And this is a standard thing, right? This is not unusual. So far, Hardrada is following the playbook that so many Vikings have done so often. He probably has about 12,000 men at this point. This includes his own son, Olaf Tostik's son who's called Skuli. They go up the Humber and then they turn into the river Uuz. People remember how they'd used the networks of rivers in what are now Russia and Ukraine. Now they're using the network of rivers
英格兰北部的河流网中如法炮制，他们沿着乌兹河北上划行，直到抵达距离约克10英里的小村庄里科尔（Riccall）。到目前为止，哈罗德所做的一切都完全合乎情理，并且计划得非常周密。他选择的是英格兰拥有最长且最深厚斯堪的纳维亚渊源的地区。他似乎不仅仅对袭扰感兴趣。我认为他很可能是认真的想要征服，这就是为什么他要攻打约克，因为约克是仅有的两个最大的城市奖品之一。只有伦敦能与之相比。它以前叫约尔维克（Yorvik），拥有庞大的斯堪的纳维亚遗产，曾是血斧埃里克（Eric Bloodaxe）的首都。你知道，那里有很多人拥有斯堪的纳维亚的家族联系、
in Northern England and they row up the Uuz northwards until they reach the village of Rikol, which is 10 miles from York. Now so far everything Harold has done has made complete sense, has been very well planned. He has gone for the area of England that is the longest and deepest Scandinavian connections. He doesn't seem to be just interested in raiding. I think he's probably serious about conquest which is why he's going for York because York is one of the two biggest urban prizes really. London is the only one that compares. It's formerly Yorvik, massive Scandinavian heritage, it'd have been the capital of Eric Bloodaxe. You know, there are a lot of people there who would have Scandinavian family connections,
根基等等，以及贸易联系。那里还有一个大主教，所以相当便利。当然，他们拉出了巨大的粪便，雄伟的维京大便。我想那是最大的粪便化石，对吧？有史以来发现的最大的粪便化石，诸如此类。所以这是一个令人闻风丧胆的地方。更让人兴奋一点的是，它还有一个造币厂。所以它是仅有的几个地方之一，是英格兰北部唯一的造币厂。如果你占领了约克，你就占据了一个真正具有某种王权权威的宝座。不管怎样，约克由最北部的两位伯爵守卫，我们已经讨论过他们很多次了。他们是
roots and so on, trading connections. There's also an archbishop, so quite convenient. And of course they, they crack out enormous turds, mighty Viking turds. I think the largest turd, isn't it? The largest fossil turd ever found, something like that. So a terrifying place. Slightly more excitingly, it also has a mint. So it's one of the only places, it's the only mint in Northern England. So if you take York, you're taking a proper seat of kind of royal authority. Anyway, York is guarded by the two
诺森布里亚伯爵莫卡（Morkar），以及麦西亚伯爵埃德温（Edwin）。他们是莱奥弗里克（Leofric）的孙子。他们是曾与戈德温逊家族分庭抗礼的伟大王朝。他们现在是哈罗德·戈德温逊的小舅子。所以他们现在效忠于哈罗德国王。现在他们俩都比哈罗德·哈德拉达年轻得多，也没有那么丰富的战斗经验。他们都二十出头。也许哈德拉达以为他们会妥协，以为他们会惊慌失措并逃跑，以为他们会投降，但他们没有。
northernmost earls and we've talked about them a lot. They are Morkar, the Earl of Northumbria, and Edwin, Earl of Mercia. They are the grandsons of Leofric. They are the dynasty that had been the great counterweight to the Godwinsons. And they're now the brothers-in-law of Harold Godwinson. So they are now loyal to Harold as king. Now they are both much younger than Hardrada and much less battle-hardened. They're both in their twenties. And it may be that Hardrada thought they would come to a deal, that they would panic and run away, that they would surrender, but they don't. Now an interesting thing here is why don't they stay in York? Because York has stone walls that are built on kind of Roman
这里有一个有趣的问题：他们为什么不待在约克城里？因为约克拥有建立在罗马地基上的石头城墙。人人都知道维京人最不喜欢做的事就是围攻城镇。他们在这方面很不擅长。他们不喜欢干这个。为什么埃德温和莫卡不直接待在约克城里，等着哈罗德·戈德温逊带着他的军队前来解围呢？最显而易见的答案是，正如你上次所描述的，哈罗德·戈德温逊为了防范诺曼人已经在南部海岸等了很久，他的手下已经开始焦躁不安，于是他解散了军队让他们回去收割庄稼。
foundations. Everybody knows the one thing the Vikings don't like doing is besieging towns. They're not terribly good at it. They don't enjoy it. Why don't Edwin and Morkar just stay in York and wait for Harold Gobinson to come in with his army and relieve them? The obvious answer is that as you described last time, Harold Gobinson has been waiting on the South Coast for ages for the Normans, and his men have become restless and he has released them to go off and bring in the harvest. harvest. So Edward and Morkar probably think, first of all, that his men are all gone, so maybe he's not going to come and relieve us anyway. But crucially, our own men have not brought in our harvest, so we don't have a lot of food in York. The city is reliant on what small stocks of food we have. And if we stay cooped up in York, Hardrada's men, they'll ravage the fields or they'll
因此，埃德温和莫卡可能认为，首先，他的手下都已经散了，所以也许他根本不会来给我们解围。但至关重要的是，我们自己的手下也没有收割我们自己的庄稼，所以我们在约克并没有储存大量的食物。这座城市全靠我们手里这点可怜的粮食储备过活。如果我们固守在约克城里，哈德拉达的手下会毁坏田地，或者他们会把所有的庄稼都吃光，而我们将会饿死。所以我们基本上别无选择，只能背水一战，逼迫对方决战。
eat all the harvest themselves and we will starve. So we basically have no choice but to force the issue. Yeah. They are bold, these pups. Is that Howard Hardrada joining us? Yes. Brilliant. So now we come to Wednesday the 20th of September.
是的。这些年轻人真是胆大妄夫。那是哈罗德·哈德拉达在加入我们吗？是的。太棒了。现在我们来到了9月20日星期三。
So that morning, Harold and Tostig are marching north along the River Ouse towards the hamlet of Fulford, which is now a southern suburb of York. And at Fulford, according to the sagas, they find their road blocked by a shield wall of about 4,000 men. And these are Edwin and Morkar's houseguards, so in other words, they're trained professional soldiers, and they're sort of levies and a real rag tag. People with pitchforks, up on a sow, I've got out my pitchfork. Exactly. People would like an axe, a bloke who's got a sling, all of this kind of thing. To describe the
那天早上，哈罗德和托斯蒂格正沿着乌兹河北上，向福尔福德（Fulford）小村庄挺进，这里现在是约克的南部郊区。在福尔福德，根据萨迦传说的记载，他们发现去路被一道由大约4,000名士兵组成的盾墙挡住了。这些是埃德温和莫卡的皇家近卫军，换句话说，他们是训练有素的职业士兵，此外还有一些征召兵和形形色色乌合之众。拿着草叉的人，站在母猪上，我拿出了我的草叉。正是此类人群。人们拿着斧头，有个家伙带着投石器，诸如此类。来描述一下
terrain, the terrain is very wet and we know that because we can tell from the name of the place. Fulford, it means foul water ford. So as the Norsemen are looking at it, they have on their left the River Ouse and on their right it's a very kind of muddy swampy area. The Norsemen are going to go uphill between these two things and they're basically going to head up and they have to cross this deep muddy ditch towards the Saxons. Now I have to say the saga's descriptions of this battle are exceedingly confusing. And historians who claim they know what happened are obviously talking about Baudelaire. And to be honest, the same is kind of true of Stamford Bridge as well.
地形，那里的地形非常潮湿，我们从地名就能看出来这一点。福尔福德（Fulford），意思是充满污水的水渡口。当诺斯人打量这里时，他们的左手边是乌兹河，右手边是一片非常泥泞沼泽地。诺斯人将在这两处地形之间往上走，他们基本上得向前推进，并且必须穿过这条深而泥泞的沟渠才能接近撒克逊人。我必须说，萨迦传说对这场战役的描述极其混乱。声称自己知道发生了什么的那些历史学家显然是在胡诌。老实说，斯坦福桥战役的情况也差不多。
Right, exactly. But what seems to have happened is this. Basically, at first Harold R. Dryder's men are going slightly uphill through all this mud. The Saxons are throwing spears and firing arrows at them. The bodies pile up, people are stumbling in the ditch and whatnot. The right hand side, the right wing of Hardrada's force, where Tostig's mercenaries are, they start to waver, we're told. Now, maybe is that because everyone hates Tostig? Or is this the sagas just trying to buttress Howard Hardrada's reputation of dissing Tostig? Who can say? According to the sagas, more car begins to push them back, then all Thumbrians end up crossing the ditch. Now some people say, well maybe was this a ploy? Was this a Battle of Hastings style ploy? Or has it been lifted
没错，完全如此。但当时似乎发生了这样的事情。基本上，起初哈罗德·哈德拉达的手下一边踩着烂泥，一边稍微往坡上走。撒克逊人向他们投掷长枪并射出箭矢。尸体堆积如山，人们在沟渠里跌跌撞撞，诸如此类。哈罗德军队的右翼，也就是托斯蒂格的雇佣兵所在的位置，据我们所知开始动摇了。现在，这究竟是因为所有人讨厌托斯蒂格？还是这只是萨迦传说在试图通过贬低托斯蒂格来抬高哈罗德·哈德拉达的声誉？谁说得准呢？根据萨迦传说的说法，莫卡开始将他们击退，随后所有诺森布里亚人最终都渡过了沟渠。现在有些人说，好吧，这难道是个计谋吗？这是一种黑斯廷斯战役风格的诱敌深入之计吗？还是说这是后人虚构出来的？
from accounts of the Battle of Hastings? Exactly. King Harold's Saga says, Harold Hardrada commanded the charge to be sounded and urged on his men. He ordered the banner, which was called the Land Waster, to be carried before him and made so severe an assault that all had to give way before it. Land Waster, his banner, very famous emblem of kind of his power, this would have been a white silk banner with a black raven on it. You know, a little nod there back to their traditions. Will Barron It said that it brings victory to whomever it proceeds into battle.
黑斯廷斯战役的记载中？确实。国王哈拉尔德传奇说，哈拉尔德·哈德拉达下令吹响冲锋号，并敦促他的部下。他命令那面被称为“土地毁灭者”的军旗走在自己前面，发起了如此猛烈的进攻，以至于所有人不得不退避三舍。“土地毁灭者”，他的军旗，象征他权力的著名标志，这是一面带有一只黑色乌鸦的白丝旗。你知道，那是对他们传统的一种小小的致敬。威廉·巴伦 据说这面旗帜能为冲入战场的人带来胜利。
Alistair Exactly. So now Hardrada orders his men into this great charge, into the gap that's been left by Morkar. There's a lot of ferocious hand-to-hand combat. And basically, the Norsemen are much better at this than the Anglo-Saxons are, than the English are. And the sagas are explicit about the scale of the slaughter. So this is King Harold's saga. He made so severe an assault that all had to give way before it. And there was a great loss among the men of the earls and they soon broke into flight, most of them leaping into the ditch, which was so filled with corpses that the Norsemen could cross it without getting wet.
阿拉斯泰尔 没错。现在，哈德拉达命令他的士兵发起宏大的冲锋，冲向莫卡留下缺口。这里有大量凶猛的近战。基本上，诺斯人比盎格루-撒克逊人更擅长此道，比英国人更擅长。萨迦传奇明确记载了这场屠杀的规模。这就是国王哈拉尔德传奇。他发起了如此猛烈的进攻，以至于所有人不得不退避三舍。伯爵的部下伤亡惨重，他们很快溃败逃跑，大多数人跳进了沟渠，沟里堆满了尸体，以至于诺斯人甚至不用弄湿鞋袜就能通过。
Then a lot of the English seem to have fled towards the river and you know bodies piling up and then river another saga Morkinskin and no greater slaughter will ever be inflicted on a brave army. So the sagas say the English did their best they fought very bravely but basically our guy was far too good for them and in the end their military power is totally broken. Now both Edwin and Morkar get away but now there's nothing between Harold Hardrada and York. He marches on York and on Sunday the 24th of September after a couple of days of faffing around city fathers have opened the gates and Harold and Tostig convene a thing,
接着，许多英国人似乎向河流方向逃去，尸体堆积如山，然后是河水，另一部萨迦《Morkinskin》记载，一支勇敢的军队从未遭受过如此巨大的屠杀。因此萨迦传奇记载，英国人尽力了，他们作战非常勇敢，但基本上我们的家伙比他们优秀得多，最后他们的军事力量彻底崩溃了。现在埃德温和莫卡都逃走了，但哈拉尔德·哈德拉达和约克之间已经没有阻碍了。他向约克进军，在9月24日星期天，经过两天的闲逛，城市长老们打开了城门，哈拉尔德和托斯蒂格召集了一场会议，
an assembly outside the city walls. And the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle tells us, they offered to grant a lasting peace to the citizens, as long as they all march south together to conquer this kingdom. So what Harold is basically, Hadrada is saying to York, the York sort of city fathers here is, you know, I'm not going to sack the city. I'm not going to pillage and loot it. Let's collaborate now. You join with me and we will take England. And actually, do you know what? There are probably a lot of people in York who think to themselves, we could actually come out quite well from this. You know, why not?
在城墙外召开了一场集会。盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史告诉我们，他们向市民提供持久的和平，条件是他们所有人一起向南进军去征服这个王国。所以哈拉尔德基本上是，哈德拉达对约克，对这里的约克城市长老们说，你知道，我不会洗劫这座城市。我不会掠夺它。我们现在合作吧。你加入我，我们将夺取英格兰。实际上，你知道吗，约克可能有很多 人心想，我们实际上可以从这件事中获得相当不错的结果。你知道，为什么不呢？
Well, because the Godwinnsons are unpopular. And the fact that Toste perhaps is at Harold's side actually serves as a reminder of everything they disliked about the Godwin Sons and perhaps, you know, they'll pitch in with Harold Hardrada. Right, and if they've pitched in with Harold Hardrada, what kind of benefits will flow Northumbria's way, York's way, as opposed to London, which will be a conquered city? Yeah, and of course for Harold Hardrada, why would he sack York? Because he needs it as his capital. Yes, exactly. So Hardrada says, okay, fine. This is what we'll do. You can give me 100 people as hostages, as a guarantee of your good behaviour. I will offer you 100 people as well. I mean,
嗯，因为戈德温森家族并受欢迎。事实上托斯蒂格可能就在哈拉尔德身边，实际上提醒了人们他们所讨厌的戈德温森家族的一切，也许，你知道，他们会投靠哈拉尔德·哈德拉达。对，如果他们投靠了哈拉尔德·哈德拉达，诺森布里亚会得到什么好处，约克会得到什么好处，而不是像被征服的城市伦敦那样？是的，当然对于哈拉尔德·哈德拉达来说，他为什么会洗劫约克？因为他需要它作为他的首都。是的，完全正确。所以哈拉尔达说，好吧，行。我们就这么办。你可以给我100名人质，作为你们行为良好的保证。我也向你们提供100个人。我是说，
historians disagree about whether these are hostages or whether actually this is basically a token garrison. Kind of collaboration. Yeah, I'll leave 100 armed hundred armed men here anyway and he says tomorrow morning which is Monday the 25th I will collect the hostages and some supplies from you and when I do that I will name the people who are gonna rule over the town and who are gonna sort out the laws and who are gonna give out land and all of that so make the final arrangements tomorrow Monday now in the meantime my men and I going back to give out land and all of that. So we'll make the final arrangements tomorrow, Monday. Now in the meantime, my men and I are going back to our ships, which are still
历史学家对这些人究竟是人质还是实际上基本上是一个代办卫戍部队意见不一。某种程度的合作。是的，无论如何我会在这里留下100名武装人员，他说明天早上，也就是9月25日星期一，我会从你们那里收集人质和一些补给品，当我这样做的时候，我会指定统治这个城镇的人，理顺法律的人，分发土地的人，所有这些——所以明天星期一做最后的安排。现在与此同时，我和我的部下去分发土地以及所有这些。所以我们明天星期一做最后的安排。现在与此同时，我和我的部下要回到我们的船上，这些船仍然
on the river at Rickall on the river Ouse, which is 10 miles away. We're going to sleep on the ships and we'll be back tomorrow. We won't come back to York. We'll get the hostages from a river crossing, an old Roman river crossing actually, called Stamford Bridge, which is eight miles east of York. That is where we will meet. And they all say, fine, we'll see you tomorrow at Stamford Bridge. So as night falls on this Sunday, Hardrada and his men have marched all the way back to the River Ooze and Rickle. And you can imagine the scene, Tom, you can deploy your laugh if you like. There is much feasting.
停泊在距离10英里外的乌斯河畔的里卡尔的河上。我们要睡在船上，明天回来。我们不会回约克。我们将在一个河渡口获取人质，实际上是一个古罗马河渡口，叫做斯坦福桥，在约克以东8英里处。那就是我们见面地方。他们都说，好的，明天斯坦福桥见。随着这个周日的夜幕降临，哈拉尔德和他的部下已经一路行军回到了乌斯河和里卡尔。你可以想象那个场景，汤姆，如果你愿意的话，你可以尽情大笑。那里有丰盛的宴席。
Right. There's a lot, there's much feasting, war stories, they're telling anecdotes about, you know, I smashed this bloke's head and it was, it was absolutely brilliant. Loved it. And you know what? Harold Hardrider is living the dream. It's all gone swimmingly. He's back on the road. Great gig. Yeah, exactly. Now for the South and for the Crown of England. But Tom, as they drain their wine cups and their drinking horns, what none of them knows is that 12 miles to the West, out of sight, entirely undetected, another army is waiting. And Tom, within just a few hours, Harold Hardrada's final adventure will reach its dramatic, heart-stopping conclusion.
对。有很多，有丰盛的宴席，战争故事，他们讲着轶事，比如，我把这家伙的头砸碎了，这简直，简直太棒了。太喜欢了。你知道吗？哈拉尔德·哈德拉达正在过着梦想中的生活。一切都进行得极其顺利。他又回到了路上。伟大的演出。是的，完全正确。现在为了南方和英格兰的王冠。但是汤姆，当他们喝干酒杯和酒角时，他们谁也不知道，在西边12英里处，视线之外，完全未被察觉的地方，另一支军队正在等待着。汤姆，在短短几个小时内，哈拉尔德·哈德拉达的最后一次冒险将迎来它戏剧性且令人窒息的结局。
This is blood pumping stuff. And we will be back after the break with the battle of Stamford Bridge. Hello. Now I'm sure you're already aware of this, but if you're not, we have some absolutely thrilling news for you. Last October, Tom and I did a live show at the Royal Albert Hall in London with an orchestra and a choir, and we enjoyed it so much that we're coming back to the Royal Albert Hall again with an orchestra to do not one, but two live shows, a matinee
这真是让人热血沸腾的内容。休息过后我们将带着斯坦福桥战役回归。你好。现在我确信你已经知道了这一点，但如果你不知道，我们有一个绝对令人兴奋的消息要告诉你。去年十月，我和汤姆在伦敦皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅与交响乐团和合唱团一起举办了一场现场演出，我们非常喜欢，以至于我们将再次带着交响乐团回到皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅，不仅举办一场，而是两场现场演出，一场日场
and an evening performance. That's right, Dominic. We will be returning to the Royal Albert Hall on the 4th of May. And once again, we will be exploring the lives of two composers on this occasion, Peter Ilyich Tchaikovsky and Richard Wagner. And once again, we will be accompanied by a full orchestra, the Philharmonia Orchestra, and the orchestra will be conducted by very much friend of the show, Oliver Zefman. That's right, Tom. And here is the really, really
和一场晚场表演。没错，多米尼克。我们将于5月4日重返皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅。我们将再次探索两位作曲家的生平，这次是彼得·伊里奇·柴可夫斯基和理查德·瓦格纳。我们将再次由完整交响乐团爱乐乐团伴奏，乐团将由演出的老朋友奥利弗·泽夫曼指挥。没错，汤姆。这里有一个真正
good news. The very last tickets have just been released and there are still one or two available and they are both for the matinee and for the evening performance. So if you're an early bird or a night owl, there are still tickets available for you. So that's The Rest is History live at the Royal Albert Hall on the 4th of May, so only a few weeks away and we will be covering the lives of Tchaikovsky and Wagner and if you want to snaffle up those last remaining tickets go to therestishistory.com that's the restish history dot com. Hello, it's Steph McGovern and Robert Peston from The Rest Is Money here. Now it's absolute carnage at the minute on the stock market across the world, all thanks to Donald Trump and his tariffs. So this week we've gone daily.
好消息。最后一批门票刚刚放出，现在还有一两张可用，日场和晚场表演的票都有。所以无论你是早起鸟还是夜猫子，都还有票留给你。这就是《历史其余部分》于5月4日在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的现场演出，距离现在只有几周时间了，我们将涵盖柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳的生平，如果你想抢购最后剩下的门票，请访问therestishistory.com，即therestishistory点com。你好，我是来自《金钱其余部分》的斯蒂夫·麦戈文和罗伯特·普斯顿。现在全球股市正经历绝对的血洗，这一切都要归功于唐纳德·特朗普和他的关税。所以本周我们改成了每日更新。
We're going to bring you shorter episodes every lunchtime. Just trying to make sense of it all because Robert, I mean, we've been in crises before, haven't we? Yeah, I mean, I've been at the front line of reporting financial crisis for decades from Black Monday in 1987 through the global financial crisis through to the COVID crisis. I mean, you know, the list goes on. This is a unique crisis because it is driven by one man Donald Trump, but it does share lots in common with those sagas we have lived through before.
我们将在每天午餐时间为您带来更短的单集。试图弄清这一切，因为罗伯特，我的意思是，我们以前也经历过危机，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，几十年来我一直处于报道金融危机的前线，从1987年的黑色星期一，到全球金融危机，再到新冠危机。我的意思是，你知道，名单还在继续。这是一场独特的危机，因为它是由于一个人唐纳德·特朗普驱动的，但它确实与我们以前经历过的那些传奇故事有许多共同之处。
And as we know, although what people see is falling share prices, it is to an extent what goes on in debt markets, financial markets, which is more important to our prosperity. And we are seeing absolute turmoil in bond markets, for example. So this is going to affect every part of our lives. Yes. And so we'll be looking at things like what do we think is going to happen next? How much pain is Trump willing to take? And what similarities are there with things like the credit crunch that you and I covered together? So to try and make sense of all of this, join
正如我们所知，尽管人们看到的是下跌的股价，但在某种程度上，债务市场、金融市场中发生的事情对我们的繁荣更为重要。我们看到债券市场出现了绝对的混乱，例如。所以这将影响我们生活的方方面面。是的。因此，我们将关注诸如我们认为接下来会发生什么？特朗普愿意承受多少痛苦？以及它与你和我一起报道的信贷紧缩等事件有什么相似之处？为了试图弄清这一切，请在
us on The Rest Is Money Money wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, welcome back. We are at dawn, Monday the 25th of September 1066. Harold Ardrada presumably waking up perhaps with a slightly sore head. There has been much drinking and feasting and fooling and he must think everything has gone absolutely brilliant. All he needs to do is go back to the meeting place outside York, pick up his hostages, pick up his supplies, and then he can turn south. And he divides his army, doesn't he? So a third stay behind at Recall to guard the ships. And those who were left behind include his son Olaf and his pledged son-in-law
你获取播客的任何地方收听《金钱其余部分》。你好，欢迎回来。我们迎来了1066年9月25日星期一的黎明。哈拉尔德·阿尔德拉达大概醒来时头有点痛。这里有大量的饮酒、宴会和恶作剧，他一定认为一切都绝对太棒了。他只需要回到约克城外的集合地点，取回他的人质，取回他的补给品，然后他就可以转向南方了。他分兵了，不是吗？所以三分之一的人留在里卡尔看守船只。留下的人包括他的儿子奥拉夫和他的既定女婿
Einstein. And then the other 8,000, he and Tosti will take them to go and get the hostages and the supplies and things. And we know that it's unseasonably warm. So the Heimskringler, the weather was uncommonly fine and the sun was very hot. So the men laid aside their armor and went ashore only with their shields, helmets, spears and swords. And many had also bows and arrows and they were all very merry. So heading off without your armor, what could possibly go wrong? So Tostey, we're told in the sagas, says, what are we doing? Let's take the armor with us. It's mad to leave our armor behind in enemy territory. I fear you've lost your wits. Tostik, we're told in the sagas, says, what are we doing? Let's take the armour with us.
爱因斯坦。然后另外8000人，他和托斯蒂格将带着他们去拿人质和补给品之类的东西。我们知道天气异常温暖。因此《海姆斯克林格》记载，天气异常晴朗，阳光非常炽热。因此士兵们脱下盔甲上岸，只带着盾牌、头盔、长矛和长剑。许多人还带着弓箭，他们都非常快乐。所以不穿盔甲就出发，究竟能出什么错呢？因此萨迦告诉我们，托斯蒂格说，我们在干什么？我们把盔甲带上吧。在敌方领土上把盔甲留下简直是疯了。我怕你疯了。萨迦告诉我们，托斯蒂格说，我们在干什么？我们把盔甲带上吧。
It's mad to leave our armour behind in enemy territory. I fear you've lost your wits. His people skills kicking in again there. We are told that everybody hates Tostik so much that, quote, nobody would listen to him. I love that detail. Now, the thing is, Tostik, of course course at this point is redundant. Really, there's no point in Tostig anymore. But you might say worse than redundant that he's an active problem because everyone in York hates him.
在敌方领土上把盔甲留下简直是疯了。我怕你疯了。他的人际交往技巧又开始发挥作用了。我们被告知每个人都非常讨厌托斯蒂格，以至于“没有人听他的”。我喜欢这个细节。现在，问题是，托斯蒂格在这个时候当然是多余的。实际上，托斯蒂格已经没有意义了。但你可能会说，比多余更糟糕的是，他是一个真正的问题，因为约克的所有人都恨他。
Exactly. So it doesn't surprise me that nobody listens to him. I mean, at this point, if you're Harold Hardrada, you're probably thinking, well, I'm going to get rid of this bloke pretty soon because I don't need him anymore. Do they leave their armor behind? There are some people who think they wouldn't. So this guy called Tom Shippey, great scholar of Norse literature, great Tolkien scholar, who says in his book Laughing Shall I Die, he says it's just not plausible that Harold Hardrada would have left his armour behind. This feels like a detail invented by saga writers to excuse his defeat. It's basically like saying you wore the wrong boots in a football match that you were expected to win. Who knows? Let's assume
绝对如此。所以没人听他的，我一点也不奇怪。我的意思是，此时此刻，如果你是哈拉尔德·哈德拉达，你可能会想，好吧，我很快就会摆脱这家伙，因为我不再需要他了。他们真的把盔甲留下了吗？有些人认为他们不会。所以这个叫汤姆·希皮的人，北欧文学的伟大学者，伟大的托尔金学者，他在他的书《大笑我去死》中说，哈拉尔德·哈德拉达把盔甲留在后面根本不合理。这感觉像是传奇作家为了开脱他的失败而编造的细节。这基本上就像是在你本该赢的一场足球比赛中穿错了靴子一样。谁知道呢？我们假设
they did leave their armour behind because the sagas are so... they emphasise it again and again. They set off towards Stamford Bridge. Now this is 15 miles away. Some of them would have had horses, most of them wouldn't, so they're proceeding probably at walking pace on what we're told is a hot day. Don Holway in his book The Last Viking about Harold Hardrada estimates that this would have taken them probably five hours or so. So in other words they probably get to Stamford Bridge when the sun's at its height around midday. We've already heard they were very merry. Of course they're in good form. They've beaten the only army in the north of
他们确实把盔甲留下了，因为传奇故事是如此……他们一次又一次地强调这一点。他们朝着斯坦福桥出发。现在这里有15英里远。他们中的一些人有马，大多数人没有，所以他们可能以步行的速度前进，据我们所知那天天气很热。唐·霍尔韦在他的关于哈拉尔德·哈德拉达的书《最后的维京人》中估计，这可能花了他们大约五个小时左右。换句话说，他们到达斯坦福桥时太阳正当空，大约在正午。我们已经听说他们非常高兴。当然他们状态很好。他们击败了英格兰北部的唯一军队。
England. There's no real threat to them. They've had a great night of feasting and we know that they haven't sent out any scouts or patrols because they the north of England. There's no real threat to them. They've had a great night of feasting. And we know that they haven't sent out any scouts or patrols because they don't really need to. Now we're told they get to this bridge across the River Derwent. It's a wooden bridge going kind of east to west. Kind of rough, rough boards across with gaps in. With gaps, yeah. Through which you could stick a sword or spear in fact. Potentially if required. So they cross the bridge from the southeastern side to the northwestern side. And now we're told in the sagas comes the key moment as they see a kind of dust cloud on the western
对他们没有真正的威胁。他们度过了一个美好的狂欢之夜，我们知道他们没有派出任何侦察兵或巡逻队，因为英格兰北部。对他们没有真正的威胁。他们度过了一个美好的狂欢之夜。我们知道他们没有派出任何侦察兵或巡逻队，因为他们真的不需要。现在我们被告知他们到达了横跨杰温河的这座桥。这是一座从东向西延伸的木桥。有点粗糙，粗糙的木板上有缝隙。有缝隙，是的。事实上你可以在缝隙里插进一把剑或长矛。如果需要的话，可能会。所以他们从东南侧过桥到西北侧。现在传奇故事告诉我们关键时刻来了，他们看到西边
horizon coming from the direction of York. And Harold Hardrada says to Tostig, what is this horsemen? And Tostig said, oh, well, this was obviously be the group bringing the hostages or maybe it's a party of kind of big wigs from York who've come to pay you, you know, homage to bend the knee as it were. And then the wonderful bit from Snorri, the nearer this force came, the greater it appeared and their shining arms glittered like a field of broken ice. Wonderful description, isn't it? And you get this sense in the sagas of Harold Hardrada watching this force
地平线上升起一团尘土，方向来自约克。哈拉尔德·哈德拉达对托斯蒂格说，这是什么？骑兵吗？托斯蒂格说，哦，好吧，这显然是带来人质的那群人，或者也许是一群来自约克的显贵，他们来向你致敬，可以说是屈膝臣服。然后是斯诺里的一段精彩描写，这支军队靠得越近，它就显得越庞大，他们闪亮的武器像一片碎冰一样闪闪发光。绝妙的描述，不是吗？你在传奇中能感受到哈拉尔德·哈德拉达看着这支军队
appear and the light glittering on the tips of the spears and this dreadful sinking feeling when he realizes, I've made a really dreadful mistake here, because these are not the hostages, this is an army. This is really one of the most dramatic, breathtaking, unexpected moments in all English history, I would say. And one of the most iconic exchanges in all of English history. So who is this? It is of course, Harold Godwinson, who's been waiting on the South
出现，光芒在长矛尖端闪烁，那种可怕的下沉感，当他意识到时，我在这里犯了一个真正可怕的错误，因为这些不是人质，这是一支军队。我认为，这真的是整个英国历史上最戏剧性、最惊心动魄、最意想不到的时刻之一。也是英国历史上最具标志性的对话之一。那么这是谁？这当然是哈拉尔德·戈德温森，他整个夏天都在南
Coast all summer to face the Normans. Now there are two versions of what has happened here. Here's the one that is the one that you learn as a child in school. And it's the really exciting one. Remember Harold Goldwinson released his men to bring in the harvest on the 8th of September and went back to London. In this sort of legendary version of the story, he hears on the 19th that Hardrada and Tostig have landed in the North.
海岸等待迎战诺曼人。现在关于这里发生了什么有两个版本。这是你在学校里作为孩子学到的那个版本。而且它是非常激动人心的那个版本。记住哈拉尔德·戈德温森在9月8日释放他的部下去收割庄稼并回到了伦敦。在这个传奇般的故事版本中，他在19号听说哈德拉达和托斯蒂格在北方登陆。
He immediately musters his men, what men he can, and then he starts riding out of London, gathering men as he passes. So that would be on the day of the Battle of Fulfa, the 20th of September. Now normally that journey to York would take two weeks and in the kind of legendary version of the story, somehow pushing his men beyond the limits of endurance. He does it in four and a half days. And for historians who love Harold Goldwinson, they say, come on, this bloke is brilliant. He's a brilliant general. He's a great organizer. And what an inspirational Churchillian figure he must be to push his men to cover such a distance
他立即召集他的部下，能召集多少就召集多少，然后他开始骑马离开伦敦，一路上不断集结部下。那将是在富尔福德战役的那天，即9月20日。通常去约克的旅程需要两周时间，而在那种传奇的故事版本中，他不知何故将他的部下推向了忍耐的极限。他在四天半内完成了。对于喜爱哈拉尔德·戈德温森的历史学家来说，他们会说，得了吧，这家伙太棒了。他是个出色的将军。他是个伟大的组织者。他一定是一个鼓舞人心的丘吉尔式的人物，才能迫使他的部下在如此短的时间内跑完这么远的距离
in so short a time. But the trend among more modern historians, more recent historians is to say, come on, if it takes you two weeks, you're not going to do it in four days. That's just not plausible. But I think they can be discounted. You think so? Yeah. The cynics explanation is that actually Harold G. Winston left much earlier, that probably he had words that Hadrada had first entered the Humber, and then he started mentoring his men, and probably it did take them about two weeks. So maybe they're not quite as exhausted. But also bear in mind, you know, we were talking in the last episode about the incredible military
。但现代历史学家、更近期的历史学家的趋势是说，得了吧，如果需要两周时间，你不可能在四天内完成。那根本不合理。但我认为它们可以被忽略。你是这么认为的？是的。愤世嫉俗者的解释是，实际上哈拉尔德·戈德温森离开得要早得多，可能他在哈德拉达首次进入亨伯河时就得到了消息，然后他开始召集部下，可能确实花了大约两周时间。所以也许他们并没有那么疲惫。但也要记住，你知道，我们在上一集里谈到过，一个英国国王能够调动的令人难以置信的军事
apparatus that an English king can command. He can command people from the North. Yes, of course. You know, there are deep reserves of manpower. They haven't all been wiped out at Fulford. So I assume he could do what seems to have happened in the wake of Stamford Bridge, which is he has a cavalry force and as he goes, he raises men who then accompany him. That's quite possible too. That is absolutely possible. Either way, by the evening of the 24th of September, so the previous evening to the day that he meets Hardrada, by that
机器。他可以调动来自北方的人。是的，当然。你知道，有深厚的人力储备。他们并没有在富尔福德被全部消灭。所以我假设他可以做在斯坦福桥之战后似乎发生的事情，那就是他有一支骑兵部队，当他前进时，他召集那些随后陪伴他的士兵。这也是完全可能的。那是绝对可能的。无论哪一种，到9月24日傍晚，也就是他遇到哈德拉达的那一天的前一天傍晚，到那个
evening he has reached the village of Tadcaster, which is 10 miles southwest of York, having covered a distance of almost 200 miles. He will undoubtedly by this point have heard about Edwin and Moorcar being defeated. He will have heard that York has surrendered. And what he does is he waits. He allows Hardrada to have his feast, to feast at the ships. He keeps a low profile. Then when door breaks, while Hardrada's off walking through the countryside with no armor, Harold Godwinson marches into York but doesn't stop there, which you might expect him to do. He keeps going. He obviously is told Hardrada is going to Stamford Bridge to get the supplies and the hostages. And Godwinson says,
傍晚，他已经到达了塔德卡斯特村，该村位于约克西南10英里处，走过的距离将近200英里。到这个时候，他无疑已经听说了埃德温和莫卡被击败的消息。他会听说约克已经投降了。他所做的是等待。他允许哈拉尔德举行盛宴，在船上大吃大喝。他保持低调。然后黎明破晓时，当哈拉尔德在没有盔甲的乡村漫步时，哈拉尔德·戈德温森开进约克，但并没有停下来，你可能会期望他这样做。他继续前进。他显然被告知哈拉尔德要去斯坦福桥获取补给和人质。戈德温森说，
right, I'm going there too and we will intercept him there. It's a bold call. He's going to risk it all on one battle. I mean, this is what people keep doing in this story, isn't it? So this is what Hardrada sees coming in the distance. Harold Godwinston with the English army and they're flying Godwinston's war banner, which is a red flag embroidered with a white fighting man. Yeah, the fighting man of Wessex. Love it. So Hardrada thinks, oh no, oh God, because the Englishmen have more men, they have 12,000 men, he perhaps has 8,000.
好吧，我也要去那里，我们将在那里拦截他。这是一个大胆的决定。他要在一场战役中孤注一掷。我的意思是，这是人们在这个故事中一直在做的事情，不是吗？所以这就是哈拉尔德在远处看到的景象。哈拉尔德·戈德温森带着英国军队，他们高举着戈德温森的战旗，那是一面绣有白色战斗人员的红旗。是的，威塞克斯的战斗人员。太棒了。所以哈拉尔德心想，哦不，哦天哪，因为英国人有更多的人，他们有12000人，他可能只有8000人。
And if we can believe the sagas, his men have by and large left their armor behind. So what's Hardrada do now? Now we're dependent completely on the Sagas really. The Sagas say he sent three men, he said, bring my three fastest riders and sent them back to Rickle for help, get the rest of the men. But if he did that, he must have known that that would take, even if they're riding really fast and then they basically move really quickly, it will take three, four hours for them to get to him. The key would be to find a bridge, say, and hold the bridge. If only there were a bridge that he could hold out at. And he says to his captains,
如果我们能相信传奇故事的话，他的部下基本上把盔甲落下了。那么哈拉尔德现在该怎么办？现在我们完全依赖于传奇故事了。传奇故事说他派了三个人，他说，把我的三个最快骑手带过来，把他们送回里卡尔寻求支援，把其余的人带过来。但如果他那样做了，他一定知道，即使他们骑得真的很快，然后他们基本上移动得非常快，也需要三、四个小时才能到达他身边。关键是要找到一座桥，比如说，守住这座桥。要是有那么一座桥能让他坚守就好了。他对他的指挥官们说，
the Englishman shall have a hard fray of it before we give ourselves up for lost. No question about that. Yeah. So now there are two great incidents that feel that they're very JRR Tolkien or the stories of King Arthur or indeed the Norse myths. First of all, he wheels his horse to bring up his army and he says, bring forth the land waster, the raven banner. And at that point, his horse stumbles and throws him to the ground in front of his men, which is a terrible omen. But he is
在我们承认失败之前，英国人将会有一场艰苦的恶战。毫无疑问。是的。现在有两个伟大的事件，感觉非常J·R·R·托尔金或亚瑟王的故事，或者确实是北欧神话。首先，他调转马头调集军队，他说：“把土地毁灭者，也就是乌鸦旗带上来。”就在那时，他的马绊了一下，把他摔倒在他的部下面前的不理，这是一个可怕的征兆。但他
quick-witted as we know, and he says, ha ha ha, our fall is good fortune. And Dominic, that is something that will also be told of William landing at Pevensey. Yes, of course. And both these accounts derive from an account in Sotonius about Julius Caesar. So to be discussed. Well, this is the thing with all these stories, right? So what is going to follow in the sagas? So many elements of this will be familiar to listeners from other battles and other such confrontations, because that's actually, of course, how the sagas worked. They worked, they're rather at Bond films. They have familiar elements that listeners, people listen to the stories, they look forward to hearing the, people listen to the stories, they
正如我们所知，机智敏捷，他说：“哈哈哈哈，我们的倒霉是好运气。”多米尼克，这也是威廉在佩文西登陆时会被讲述的事情。是的，当然。这两个记载都源于苏托尼乌斯关于尤利乌斯·凯罗的一则记载。因此有待讨论。好吧，所有这些故事都是这样，对吧？那么萨迦传奇中接下来会发生什么？听众会从其他战役和类似的对抗中熟悉这里的许多元素，因为这实际上正是萨迦传奇的运作方式。它们运作起来，更像是詹姆斯·邦德电影。它们有熟悉的元素，听众，听故事的人，他们期待听到，听故事的人，他们
look forward to hearing the bit where the king is going to fall off his horse and say, ha ha, that is good fortune, because they like those elements of the story. I think also with the Hadrada specifically, there's the issue of the land waster always guaranteeing victory to whoever has it. And so there is a need on this occasion to explain why that might not necessarily be the case. At this point, we hear Harold Godwinson speak and Harold Godwinson says to his men, who was that tall man whose horse fell with a blue tunic on the beautiful helm? Now he's talking we're told to Norsemen who are fighting for him. And that's not implausible, is it? I mean,
期待听到国王从马上摔下来并说“哈哈，那是好运气”的那个部分，因为他们喜欢故事的这些元素。我认为对于哈拉尔德·哈德拉达来说，也有关于土地毁灭者总是向拥有它的人保证胜利的问题。因此在这种情况下有必要解释为什么情况可能不一定是这样。此时，我们听到哈拉尔德·戈德温森说话，哈拉尔德·戈德温森对他的部下说：“那个穿蓝色束腰外衣、戴着漂亮头盔、骑着马摔倒的高个子男人是谁？”现在我们被告知他是在跟为他作战的诺斯人说话。这并非不可信，不是吗？我是说，
these are not ethnically homogenous armies. Harold is half Scandinavian himself, Harold Godwinson. And these Norsemen apparently say, that was the King of Norway. And Harold Godwinson is given the splendid line, he looks like a grim and splendid man, but I think his luck has run out. Harold Godwinson in these epics, and I think you get the sense of him actually from contemporaneous accounts, there is a quality of Clint Eastwood in a spaghetti western. He's very cool and there's a kind of a dryness to his humor that seems authentic to the man.
这些并不是种族单一的军队。哈拉尔德本人就是半个斯堪的纳维亚人，哈拉尔德·戈德温森。这些诺斯人显然说，那是挪威国王。哈拉尔德·戈德温森说出了一句精彩的话，他看起来像个冷酷而辉煌的人，但我认为他的好运已经用完了。这些史诗中的哈拉尔德·戈德温森，我认为你可以从同时代的记载中感受到他的特质，有一种意大利西部片中克林特·伊斯特伍德的风范。他非常冷酷，他的幽默中有一种干练，这似乎与这个人的本色相符。
Well, we'll see in the next exchange the great demonstration of this and this I have to say for me is one of the great conversations, one of the legendary conversations in all English history, not just medieval history but all English history and there are so many different versions in the sagas and chronicles and things that there must be I think some kernel of truth here and to be frank I want there there must be, I think, some kernel of truth here. And to be frank, I want there to be. But Dominic, remember that wonderful description of Harold Godwinson going through life with
好吧，我们在接下来的对话中将看到这一点的精彩展示，我必须说，对我来说，这是英国历史上最伟大的对话之一，传奇对话之一，不仅是中世纪历史，而且是整个英国历史，萨迦和编年史等资料中有如此多不同的版本，我认为这里一定有某种核心真相，坦率地说，我希望这里一定有某种核心真相，坦率地说，我希望有。但是多米尼克，还记得对哈拉尔德·戈德温森一生中带着警惕的嘲弄一次次穿过伏击的精彩描述吗，那是同时代的。我认为这场对话也有这种特质。
watchful mockery through ambush after ambush, which is contemporaneous. And there is a quality of that about this exchange, I think. Totally there is. So the English have halted. They've approached the Scandinavians. They're at two bow shots away with a group of them ride forward, their banner's flowing. I mean, this is absolute kind of riders of Rohan kind of territory. Their leader, his face is masked behind a gilded helmet and he calls out,
完全有。所以英国人停了下来。他们接近了斯堪的纳维亚人。他们距离两个弓箭射程，其中一群人向前骑行，他们的旗帜飘扬。我的意思是，这绝对是罗汉骑士那种风格的地盘。他们的领袖，他的脸被隐藏在一个镀金头盔后面，他大声喊道，
is Earl Tostig here? Tostig says, rather bizarrely, I cannot deny it. And this man says, your brother King Harold greets you and sends you this offer. He would prefer not to fight you and offers you all Northumbria, a third of his kingdom. Tostig, my brother should have offered me that last winter instead of his enmity and spite. That would have been better for England. And then Tostig speaks again, if I accept this offer what will my brother give Harold son of Sigurd, meaning Hardrada, and then the Englishman has the absolutely excellent line, he will give him seven feet of English ground or more if he really is so much taller but no more than that. So for his grave,
托斯蒂格伯爵在这里吗？托斯蒂格相当奇怪地回答说，我无法否认这一点。这个人说，你的兄弟哈拉尔德国王向你问好，并向你提供这个提议。他宁愿不跟你打仗，并向你提供整个诺森布里亚，他王国的三分之一。托斯蒂格回答说，我兄弟去年冬天就应该向我提供这个，而不是他的敌意和恶意。这对英格兰会更好。然后托斯蒂格再次开口，如果我接受这个提议，我兄弟会给西居尔之子哈拉尔德，也就是哈德拉达什么，然后英国人说出了那句绝对精彩的话，他会给他七英尺宽的英格兰土地，如果他真的长得那么高，甚至更多，但仅此而已。为了他的坟墓，
for his grave. Now Tostig, who has been a complete snake so far in the story, then he doesn't take the deal. He says, tell my brother to make ready for battle and never let men say that Tostig betrayed Harold Sigurdsson when he came west to fight for England, for we have vowed to win the kingdom or die with honour. Now the Sagas, who have no vested interest in being nice to Tostig, they're very kind to Tostig at this point. They're saying Tostig actually, you know, he doesn't take the deal. He doesn't betray Harold Hardrada. Well, they do love an epic exchange, don't they?
为了他的坟墓。现在托斯蒂格，在故事中到目前为止一直是个彻底的阴险小人，然后他没有接受这笔交易。他说，告诉我的兄弟做好战斗准备，绝不要让人们说托斯蒂格在哈拉尔德·西居尔松西征为英格兰而战时背叛了他，因为我们已经发誓要赢得王国或带着荣誉死去。现在那些对对托斯蒂格好没有既得利益的萨迦传奇，在此时对托斯蒂格非常友善。他们说托斯蒂格实际上，你知道，他没有接受这笔交易。他没有背叛哈拉尔德·哈德拉达。嗯，他们确实喜欢史诗般的对话，不是吗？
They love an epic exchange. And then the splendid bit, Hardrada, who hasn't understood a word of this because he doesn't speak English. He says to Tostig, who was that man who spoke so fair? And Tostig says, that was my brother, Harold Godwinson. And Hardrada says, he is a small man, but he stood well in his stirrups. It's so brilliant, isn't it? Everybody is so great in this story. And those are the last words that will ever be spoken between the two brothers. And again, from Harold, you get this wit, this kind of defiant, cool, that you feel must be, must be true to the man.
他们喜欢史诗般的对话。然后是精彩的部分，哈德拉达一个字也没听懂，因为他不会说英语。他对托斯蒂格说，那个说话那么好听的人是谁？托斯蒂格说，那是我的兄弟，哈拉尔德·戈德温森。哈拉尔德说，他是个小个子男人，但他马鞍骑得很稳。太棒了，不是吗？每个人在这个故事里都这么伟大。这些将是两兄弟之间说的最后一句话。同样，从哈拉尔德身上，你能感受到这种机智、这种挑衅、这种冷酷，让你觉得这一定，一定符合这个人的真实性格。
Why is this not the most popular Amazon TV drama of all time? So now they make the final preparations for battle. The English, remember, have about 12,000 men. The Norwegians about 8,000. They, they have not been transformed by the same military revolution that has taken place in Normandy. So this is not going to be a battle with knights and with great cavalry charges and stuff. There is some of that in the sagas, but most people think these are anachronisms, these are later embellishments borrowed from the Battle of Hastings. What's so amazing about 1066, isn't it? That you have a battle that could have been fought
为什么这不是有史以来最受欢迎的亚马逊电视剧集呢？所以现在他们为战斗做最后的准备。记住，英国人大约有12000人。挪威人大约有8000人。他们没有经历过在诺曼底发生的同样的军事革命。所以这将不是一场有骑士、有伟大骑兵冲锋等内容的战役。萨迦中确实有一些那样的内容，但大多数人认为这些是时代错误，是后来从黑斯廷斯战役中借用的润色。1066年真正神奇的地方在于，不是吗？你有一场本可以在八世纪打响的战役。
in the eighth century. And you have this other battle at Hastings, which presages all the battles that will be fought over the course of the high middle ages. It's a year with dragonships and with castles. Yeah, exactly. It's like two time periods colliding. That's what makes it such a brilliant story. So the odds very clearly, if you think they've got the same military technology, they're both kind of tired. The odds clearly favour the English, especially if the Norwegians don't have any armour.
而你有另一场黑斯廷斯战役，它预示了整个盛期中世纪将要打响的所有战役。这是一个充满龙船和城堡的年份。是的，完全正确。就像两个时代的碰撞。这就是为什么它是一个如此精彩的故事。所以胜算非常明显，如果你认为他们拥有相同的军事技术，他们都有些疲惫。胜算明显偏向英国人，特别是如果挪威人没有任何盔甲的话。
And in good epic style, the sagas have Hardrada murmuring, composing poems as he draws up his men. Tom Shippey's translation, I've slightly adapted it. At first, Hardrada says, forward we go in formation, without our armor against blue steel edges, helmets shine. I don't have mine. Now our armor lies down with the ships. Now this is quite depressing for him.
带着良好的史诗风格，萨迦传奇让哈拉尔德·哈德拉达在排兵布阵时低声吟诵、创作诗歌。汤姆·希皮的翻译，我稍微改编了一下。起初，哈拉尔德说：“我们列队前进，不穿盔甲面对蓝色的钢刃，头盔闪闪发光。我没有我的。现在我们的盔甲和船只躺在一起。”现在这对他来说相当沮丧。
Nice internal rhyme scheme though. Very nice, very internal rhyme scheme though. Very nice, very nice rhyme scheme. But then apparently the saga says, Hardrider says, oh come on, this is, that's a bit defeatist. I'll compose a better verse. And this is Tom Shippett's translation again. Again, I've slightly adapted it. We should not creep into battle behind the hollow of our shields because of the crush of weapons. So commanded Faithful Hill, the Valkyrie. The woman once told me to hold my head high where ice blades meet skulls in
不过内部韵律很好。非常棒，非常内部韵律很好。非常棒，非常棒的韵律。但接着显然萨迦传奇说，哈拉尔德说，“哦，得了吧，这有点失败主义。我会创作一首更好的诗。”这是汤姆·希皮的翻译。再次，我稍微改编了一下。“我们不应该因为武器的挤压而躲在盾牌后面偷偷摸摸进入战场。忠诚的希尔，瓦尔基丽就是这么命令的。那个女人曾经告诉我，在冰刃与头盔在剑术冲突中相遇的地方，要把头抬高。”
the clash of swords." What that basically means is let's do this, let's do it straight, let's not hide behind our shields, let's meet this face on. Now I don't think for a moment that Harold Hardrada is genuinely standing there composing poems, but I think this does capture something of the essence of the man. He is always a... I'm not sure about that. I think it's possible. We know from historical evidence much later, the Elves of Orkney, when they go on these kind of great expeditions, and some of them are famous for composing, extemporizing poetry
这基本上意味着让我们干吧，让我们正面来，不要躲在我们的盾牌后面，让我们直面这一切。现在我一刻也不认为哈拉尔德·哈德拉达真的站在那里创作诗歌，但我认为这确实捕捉到了这个人的某些本质。他总是……我对这一点不太确定。我认为这是可能的。我们从历史证据中得知，很久以后，奥克尼的精灵们，当他们进行这种伟大的远征时，其中一些人以创作、即兴创作这样的诗歌而闻名。所以这并非不可能。
like this. So it's not impossible. This is great that you've dropped your scepticism. See, I want to dial up the melodrama. I think Harold Hardrider definitely composed poems. These are those exact poems. Because I think the poems are likely to be more authentic than the actual details of the battle. Do you? Well. They're the kind of things that might have been preserved.
你放下了怀疑，这真是太棒了。你看，我想调高情节剧的戏剧张力。我认为哈拉尔德·哈德拉达绝对创作了诗歌。这些就是那些确切的诗歌。因为我认为这些诗歌可能比战役的实际细节更具真实性。是吗？嗯。它们是那种可能被保存下来的东西。
Well, on the details of the battle. So the Battle of Stamford Bridge, one of the great battles in English history. What do we know about it? If you read King Harold's saga, Snorri Sturluson, written in the 1230s, there are knights charging, people running away, all kinds of twists and turns. It's the Battle of Hastings. It's the Battle of Hastings. If you read the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, you're like, well, what's the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle say? I should tell you what it said. It said, they continued fighting all day. Come on, give us more detail.
嗯，关于战役的细节。所以斯坦福桥战役，英国历史上伟大的战役之一。我们对它了解多少？如果你读过写于1230年代的斯诺里·斯图鲁松的《国王哈拉尔德传奇》，那里有骑士冲锋、人们逃跑、各种各样的曲折离奇。这就是黑斯廷斯战役。这就是黑斯廷斯战役。如果你读《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》，你会想，好吧，《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》是怎么说的？我应该告诉你它说了什么。它说，他们整天都在战斗。得了吧，给我们更多细节。
Have you been to the site of the battle? I've never been there. It's basically a housing estate. So I went to have a look at it. There's a pub, there's a bridge, there's a little, there are kind of little hints of it, but it's quite hard to get a sense of the terrain. Please tell me there's a visitor center of some kind. No, I think there's a board. Oh no. On the side of a kind of community centre.
你去过战役遗址吗？我从未去过那里。那基本上是一个住宅区。所以我去看了看。那里有一个酒吧，有一座桥，有一点点，有一些微小的迹象，但很难对地形产生感觉。请告诉我那里有某种游客中心。不，我想有一个布告牌。哦不。在一个某种社区中心的侧面。
So there should be a virtual reality immersive experience, you know, be in the thick of the action. Yeah, ravens. Right. Whistling of arrows. Yeah, all of that. So let's go with the sagas, which are the, yeah, and try to, I'm just going to try to have some fun with the sagas and see what we think could have happened. Hardrada wants to hold off the English for as long as possible before, let's say, 4,000 men arrive from Rickle.
所以应该有一个虚拟现实沉浸式体验，你知道的，身临其境体验激烈的战斗。是的，乌鸦。对。箭矢的呼啸声。是的，所有这些。所以让我们根据萨迦传奇来，传奇是，是的，并尝试，我只是想在萨迦传奇中找点乐子，看看我们认为可能发生了什么。哈拉尔德希望在，比如说，4000人从里卡尔赶到之前，尽可能长时间地拖住英国人。
They'll take four hours. So he's got a long time to fight. But as you said, that bridge is going to come in very useful. So it's a narrow wooden footbridge we're told. We're also told the banks of the river are too steep and the water is too deep to cross anywhere but the bridge. If you're on the other side, the English have to, they can only use the footbridge to cross. So he puts most of his men, the sagas say, on the far sort of southeastern bank. And then he orders his elite, his vanguard, his houseguards, his trained
他们需要四个小时。所以他有很长时间可以战斗。但正如你所说，那座桥将非常有用。所以我们被告知那是一座狭窄的木制人行桥。我们还被告知河岸太陡，水太深，除了桥之外任何地方都无法渡过。如果你在另一侧，英国人必须，他们只能使用人行桥过河。所以萨迦传奇说，他把大部分士兵放在了遥远的东南岸。然后他命令他的精锐、他的前卫、他的近卫队、他的训练有素的
professional soldiers to form a shield wall at the far end of the bridge, the western bank and basically if they can hold the bridge they will be alright. And then, say the sagas, there is this long struggle. The English are firing arrows at them, throwing spears at them, basically trying to dislodge this shield war from the narrow footbridge because once they've got the bridge they can then pour across and attack the rest of the Norwegians. And in the English sources that we have, later chronicles, let's say a hundred years later some of them, they tell the story, again it does feel a little bit like a well-known formula, that one by one, the Norsemen are whittled down until there is just one anonymous Norseman
职业士兵在桥的另一端、即西岸组成一面盾墙，基本上只要他们能守住桥，他们就会没事。然后，萨迦传奇说，是一场漫长的斗争。英国人向他们发射箭矢，向他们投掷长矛，基本上试图将这面盾墙从狭窄的人行桥上赶走，因为一旦他们拿下了桥，他们就可以蜂拥过桥并攻击其余的挪威人。在我们拥有的英国史料中，后来的编年史，比如说其中一些是一百年后写的，他们讲述了这个故事，这确实感觉有点像一个众所周知的公式，一个接一个，
holding the bridge alone against the English. So this is Henry of Huntingdon. He was born at about 1088. So he's born about 20 years after the battle. Might he have heard eyewitness accounts? I mean, it's hard to know. But anyway, this is what he says. A single Norwegian whose name should have been remembered posted himself on the bridge and chopping down more than 40 English with a battle axe, his country's weapon, halted the advance of the whole English army. And this
诺斯人被消灭，直到只剩下一个匿名的诺斯人独自在桥上对抗英国人。这就是亨廷顿的亨利。他大约生于1088年。所以他大约生于战役后20年。他可能听到过目击者的叙述吗？我的意思是，很难知道。但无论如何，这就是他所说的：一个挪威人，他的名字本应被人们记住，他站在桥上，用战斧——他国家的武器——砍倒了40多个英国人，阻挡了整个英国军队的推进。而这个
is William of Malmesbury and you said Tom, I think that he's about the same generation, isn't he? So he might again just have heard eyewitness accounts. I mean, William of Malmesbury is a very great historian, probably the greatest English historian since Bede, so not to be discounted altogether. Well let us believe him. He says, given the chance to surrender and being assured that a man of such bravery could expect the greatest mercy from the English, he this is this lone Norseman ridiculed those who tried to bargain with him and scorned the cowards who were unable to overcome one man. And then this very memorable moment,
这就是马姆斯伯里的威廉，你刚才说汤姆，我觉得他和他是差不多同一代人，对吧？所以他可能也只是听过目击者的叙述。我的意思是，马姆斯伯里的威廉是一位非常伟大的历史学家，可能是自比德以来最伟大的英国历史学家，所以不能完全不把他的话当回事。好吧，让我们相信他。他说，在有机会投降并被保证像他这样勇敢的人可以从英国人那里得到最大的仁慈时，这位孤独的挪威人嘲笑了那些试图跟他讨价还价的人，并鄙视了那些连一个人都战胜不了的懦夫。然后，在这个非常难忘的时刻，
one Englishman gets under the bridge. Some accounts say he's sort of made a makeshift boat for himself and is kind of floating under the bridge. And then he stabs his sword up through the planks of the bridge. That gap between the boards that we mentioned before? The gap between the boards into the Norseman's Nether parts? Nether regions, exactly. The Norseman falls, a great cheer erupts from the English army, and then like kind of the orcs at the end of the Fellowship of the Ring. They pour across the bridge.
一个英国人钻到了桥底。有些记载说他给自己弄了一种临时的小船，有点像是在桥底下漂着。然后他用剑刺穿了桥上的木板。就是我们之前提到的木板之间的缝隙？板子之间的缝隙，直接刺中了挪威人的下半身？下三路，没错。挪威人倒下了，英国军队爆发出一阵巨大的欢呼声，然后就像《指环王》结局时的半兽人一样。他们蜂拥过桥。
Dominic, you're not comparing the English to the orcs. Yeah, but Tom, I don't actually think that. This is what a great historian does with his imagination. I'm seeing it from the Norwegian perspective. I just want to pay tribute here to my very first history teacher, Major Morris. He would narrate our stories, very like you Dominic, but he was also a brilliant artist and he drew a picture of this sole Norseman standing on the bridge smiting the English and then he did one of the Englishmen in the boat gliding up to the bridge and then he had an excellent drawing of the spear being shoved up through
多米尼克，你可别把英国人比作半兽人。是的，但汤姆，我其实不是这么想的。这就是一个伟大的历史学家用他的想象力在做的事。我是从挪威人的角度来看待这件事的。我只想在这里向我的第一位历史老师莫里斯少校致敬。他给我们讲故事时，非常像你，多米尼克，但他同时也是一位出色的艺术家，他画了一幅画，画的是这个孤独的挪威人站在桥上痛击英国人，然后他又画了一个坐在船上滑向桥边的英国人，接着他画了一幅极佳的画，画的是长矛从
the gap. Oh no way. And the Norseman kind of arms and legs going out and I must have been, I don't know, eight, nine when I saw that and I've never forgotten it. I can't compete with that because actually my art teacher when I was that age said I was the single worst person she'd ever taught in her 40-year career. Mrs. Salt. That was her verdict. So I can't compete with Major Morris, I'm afraid. So what happens next? The English have piled across the bridge. What can we tell from the sagas? What probably happened? Almost certainly the Norwegians would have formed a shield wall, a defensive shield wall and tried to hold out. And we can assume that effectively the English surrounded
缝隙里刺了进去。哦，不会吧。挪威人手脚张开倒下去，我当时一定，我不知道，八、九岁吧，当我看到那个画面时，我永远不会忘记它。我没法跟这个比，因为实际上我那个年纪的美术老师说我是她40年教学生涯中教过的绝对最差的人。索尔太太。那是她的评价。所以恐怕我没法跟莫里斯少校比。那么接下来发生了什么？英国人蜂拥过桥。我们能从萨迦史诗中知道些什么？可能发生了什么？几乎可以肯定，挪威人会组成一个盾墙，一个防御性的盾墙，并试图坚守。我们可以假设，实际上英国人包围了
them again. And then Dominic has a great historian kind of entered into the mind of Harold. And if he has, shall I read what this great historian, namely yourself, has written about it? So to explain, we're told in the sagas that Harold decides on one final charge without his helmet, without his armor. And again, the mark of a great historian, Tom, is their use of the imagination as well as the sources. Yes, so this is what you write in Adventures in Time.
他们。然后，多米尼克，作为伟大的历史学家，你是否进入了哈罗德的内心世界？如果是的话，我是否可以读一读这位伟大的历史学家，也就是你自己，关于这段经历的描述？解释一下，萨迦史诗告诉我们，哈罗德决定在不戴头盔、不穿盔甲的情况下发起最后一次冲锋。汤姆，再次证明一个伟大历史学家的标志是他们对想象力的运用以及对史料的使用。是的，这就是你在《时间的冒险》中所写的。
With two hands he raised his huge steel-ringsword and whispered one last prayer. Then, with a terrible roar of berserker fury, he hurled himself into the fray, and as he raged and slew, all his cares seemed to melt away, and he felt a lightness and joy he had not known for many years." So that's you inhabiting the mind of a Berserker warrior. Unbelievable! But you know, it's method writing, because I'm imagining my own mood before we do one of our Rest His History live shows on tour. That is very much what you're like.
他双手举起巨大的钢环剑，低声作了最后一次祷告。接着，伴随着狂战士般的狂怒和可怕的咆哮，他把自己掷入了战局，随着他狂怒厮杀，他所有的忧虑似乎都消融了，他感到了多年未曾有过的轻松与快乐。”所以这就是你化身为了狂战士。难以置信！但你知道，这是体验派写作，因为我在想象我们进行“历史其余部分”巡回现场秀之前的自己的心情。那真的很像你的状态。
You kind of froth at the mouth, don't you? Yeah. We'll read the next bit and people will see exactly what I'm like before a show. On he charged, his face a mask of dripping blood, a war cry on his lips, a battle song in his heart. He felt wonderfully happy. He had never been happier. That's literally how I feel just before we go on stage to answer the listeners questions. What's your favorite historical dinner party? Who would win a fight between
你有点口吐白沫，对吧？是的。我们读下一段，大家就会看到我演出前到底是什么样子的。他向前冲锋，面部血迹斑斑，嘴里喊着战号，心中唱着战歌。他感到无比快乐。他从未如此快乐过。这简直就是我在上台回答听众问题之前的真实感受。你最喜欢的历史晚宴是哪个？谁能在
Jacko Macaco and Napoleon? That's exactly how I feel. So this is literally what happened to Harold Hardrada to be clear. In the sagas he is killed either with an arrow or with a spear in the throat. I think these details are very clearly taken from the Battle of Hastings. But you know what Tom, he deserves an ending like that. He does. I think he died just like Boromir at Parth-Gharlan at the end of the Fellowship of the Ring. So I think he is surrounded by English bodies.
杰克·马卡科和拿破仑之间的决斗中获胜？这正是我的感受。所以这确实就是哈拉尔德·哈德拉达的真实结局。在萨迦中，他是被一支箭或咽喉处的一根长矛杀死的。我认为这些细节显然取材于黑斯廷斯战役。但你知道吗，汤姆，他配得上这样的结局。他确实配得上。我想他死得就像《指环王》结尾帕斯吉兰的博罗米尔一样。所以我想他是被英国人的尸体包围着的。
He's in a pile of bodies. He's peppered with arrows. And obviously all of this is the stuff that Tolkien has saturated. Of course. I mean, it must be on Tolkien's mind, as Tom Shippey would, you know, I'm sure absolutely agree. Absolutely. So Harold Hardrada falls and dies, let us hope in this incredibly dramatic and worthy way. Snorri Sturluson says that at this point Harold Goldwynson paused and he said to the remaining Northmen and Tostig who's still alive, we will give you peace and quarter if you surrender. And again, Tostig behaves very gallantly. He says, no, I won't.
他倒在一堆尸体中。他浑身插满了箭。显然，所有这些都是托尔金浸润过的素材。当然。我的意思是，托尔金脑子里一定在想这些，正如汤姆·希佩会完全同意的那样，我确信绝对如此。完全正确。所以哈拉尔德·哈德拉达阵亡了，让我们希望他是以这种极其戏剧化且悲壮的方式死去的。斯诺里·斯图鲁松说，就在这时，哈罗德·戈德温森停了下来，他对剩下的北欧人和仍然活着的托斯蒂说，如果你投降，我们将给予你和平与宽恕。托斯蒂表现得非常英勇。他说，不，我不会。
No, let's finish this. Let's go to the end. So there's a scale called Arnold who's quoted by the sagas. The gallant men who saw him fall would take no quarter, him being Harold Hardrada. One and all resolved to die with their loved king around his corpse in a corpse ring. So I think that's terrible. Yeah, I think that's brilliant. I actually almost started crying when I was reading that, I was so moved. So by now the Norwegian reinforcements are finally arriving, but it's far too late. Many of them are cut down too. And a few survivors, dozens, hundreds, it's hard to tell, do make it back to Rickle. They flee across the countryside. Well, it's 24 ships go and it was 300 ships that had arrived, isn't it?
不，让我们结束这一切吧。让我们走到最后。萨迦史诗中引用了一位名叫阿诺德的诗人的话。那些看到他倒下的英勇之人在哈拉尔德·哈德拉达倒下时绝不接受宽恕。他们众口一词，决心与他们深爱的国王死在一起，在尸环中倒下。所以我觉得这太可怕了。是的，我觉得这太精彩了。我读到这里时甚至差点哭出来，我太感动了。到现在，挪威的增援部队终于赶到了，但为时已晚。他们中的许多人也被砍倒了。少数幸存者，几十人还是几百人很难说，确实逃回了里克尔。他们逃过乡野。嗯，有24艘船离开，而到达的有300艘船，不是吗？
Exactly. Harold Hadrada and Tostig's sons were not in the battle. They'd stayed with the ships. And the next day they rode under flag of truce to York where Harold Gobinson had installed himself victorious. And he was as biff as you would expect from Harold Gobinson, who's one of the greatest men who ever lived. He's very generous to them. And he was as you would expect from Harold Gobinson, who's one of the greatest men who ever lived. He's very generous to them. And he says, look, you know, it's a fair fight. You know, all's fair in love and war. You can sail back to Norway as long as you don't do this again. But he wants them to go.
没错。哈拉尔德·哈德拉达和托斯蒂的儿子们没有参加战斗。他们留在了船上。第二天，他们打着休战旗骑马来到约克，哈罗德·戈德温森正以胜利者的姿态驻扎在那里。他表现得像你所期待的哈罗德·戈德温森那样大度，他是历史上最伟大的人之一。他对他们非常慷慨。正如你对哈罗德·戈德温森的期望那样，他对待他们极其慷慨，他是曾活过的人中最伟大的人物之一。他说，听着，这是一场公平的战斗。爱与战争中一切皆公平。只要你们不再这样做，你们就可以航行回挪威。但他希望他们离开。
And as you said, Tom, it takes them only 24 of their 300 ships to take the survivors back because so many have fallen. And Dominic, to the land of the Northmen came only a tale from far off, a rumour of the wrath and terror of Wessex. Oh, I love that. Is that you? No, it's from Tolkien. Oh, that's very good. Well done, Tolkien. It's the last sentence describing the battle of Pelennor fields. And I have replaced Gondor with Wessex. Oh, that's very good. Well done Tolkien. It's the last sentence describing the battle of Pelennor fields and I have replaced Gondor with Wessex. Oh that's very good. So that's one for you, one for Tabby and one
正如你所说，汤姆，他们300艘船中只有24艘带走了幸存者，因为太多人阵亡了。多米尼克，“对于北欧人的土地，只传去了远方的一个故事，一个关于威塞克斯的愤怒与恐怖的传闻。”哦，我太喜欢这句了。这是你写的吗？不，这是出自托尔金。哦，太棒了。干得好，托尔金。这是描写佩兰诺平原战役的最后一句。我把刚多替换成了威塞克斯。哦，太棒了。干得好，托尔金。这是描写佩兰诺平原战役的最后一句话，我把刚多换成了威塞克斯。哦，这太棒了。所以，一个送给你，一个送给塔比，还有
for Tolkien fans everywhere. Crikey. Well Tabby, Tolkien fans and I are all delighted by that I imagine. So this is the last gasp Tom of the Viking Age. Or is it? Well, well is it? Is it actually because you could make two arguments here. One you could say the Viking Age. Or is it? Well, is it? Is it actually? Because you could make two arguments here. One you could say the Viking Age is already over because of course Christianity has already began to transform Scandinavia. We've had towns arriving in Scandinavia, we've got kings, the days of you know, freebooting raiders are gone actually.
一个送给全世界的托尔金粉丝。天哪。好吧，塔比，我想托尔金的粉丝和我都为此感到高兴。汤姆，这可以说是维京时代的最后一声叹息。还是说并非如此？好吧，真的是吗？真的是这样吗？因为你在这里可以提出两种论点。一方面你可以说维京时代。或者是吗？好吧，是吗？真的是这样吗？因为你在这里可以提出两个论点。一方面你可以说维京时代已经结束了，因为当然基督教已经开始改变斯堪的纳维亚。斯堪的纳维亚出现了城镇，我们有了国王，海盗掠夺的时代其实已经一去不复返了。
And Harold Hardrada in many ways is not a Viking. The other way you could say it's actually the Viking Age still has some time to run because there will be more Scandinavian attacks. Svein, who sensibly turned down Tostig's offer, he does actually launch two raids after the Norman Conquest. One of those has a very decisive impact on the course of William's reign as we will see. It does indeed. And in fact, I was surprised when I looked this up. The last really serious attack, it was as late as 1152, a guy called Einstein the second, who was Harold Hardrada's great-great-grandson raided the East coast of England.
从很多方面来看，哈拉尔德·哈德拉达都不是一个维京人。另一种说法是，维京时代其实还有一段时间要走，因为还会有更多来自斯堪的纳维亚的袭击。斯文，他明智地拒绝了托斯蒂的提议，实际上在诺曼征服后发动了两次袭击。正如我们将看到的，其中一次袭击对威廉统治的进程产生了非常决定性的影响。确实如此。事实上，当我查阅资料时，我很惊讶。最后一次真正严重的袭击甚至到了1152年，一个名叫埃斯泰因二世的人，他是哈拉尔德·哈德拉达的玄孙，袭击了英格兰东海岸。
So retro, isn't it? You know, you're busy talking about the Crusades and things. Oh my God, it's a Viking. Come on, mate, it's the 12th century. But you can understand completely why people call Harold Hardrada the last Viking and why people always use this to end their kind of Viking survey books. Because there is something about him, the mad adventures of his life, his travels, but also his sensibility, composing all these poems in the face of danger, kind of laughing uncontrollably for no good reason.
真是太复古了，不是吗？你知道的，你正忙着谈论十字军东征之类的事情。天哪，这是一个维京人。得了吧，老兄，这可是12世纪。但你完全可以理解为什么人们称哈拉尔德·哈德拉达为最后一个维京人，为什么人们总是用这个人物来作为他们这类维京人普查书籍的结尾。因为他身上有一种特质，他疯狂的一生历险、他的旅行，还有他的感性，在危险面前谱写所有的诗歌，毫无理由地无法控制地大笑。
I mean, I guess I would just stick up for the ills of Orkney, who do kind of hang around on the scene and continue to lead a Viking life, composing poems and going on expeditions and things. You've got to admit, Tom, they don't quite have the same cultural cachet as Harold Ardrada. No, they don't, but they are still around on the scene. Tom Shippey has a lovely line where he's talking about the way he dies and he says, even the way he dies at Stamford Bridge, this hubristic end where he's left his armour behind, or has he?
我的意思是，我想我会为奥克尼的伯爵们说句公道话，他们确实在现场转悠，继续过着维京人的生活，写诗、进行远征等等。你得承认，汤姆，他们的文化声望确实不如哈拉尔德·阿德拉达。不，他们确实比不上，但他们仍然活跃在现场。汤姆·希佩有一句很精彩的话，当他谈到哈拉尔德的死法时，他说，甚至他在斯坦福桥的死法，这种狂妄自大的结局，他把盔甲留在了身后，或者真的是这样吗？
Let's assume he's left his armour behind and he's surrounded by the English, but he fights on to the end. Tom Shubbie says, this feels like the embodiment of the Viking spirit, arrogant, unlucky, self-possessed to the last and accepting his fate with wry defiance. So that's the end of Harold Hardrada. But what of the victor? What of the man who's beaten him? I think Harold Goldwinson has won an astounding victory. It is one of the greatest victories at this point in the history of the English people. I mean, surely equivalent to any of the victories
让我们假设他把盔甲留在了身后，他被英国人包围，但他一直战斗到最后一刻。汤姆·希佩说，这感觉就像是维京精神的化身，傲慢、不幸、临危不乱，带着苦涩的挑衅接受了自己的命运。这就是哈拉尔德·哈德拉达的结局。但是胜利者呢？那个击败他的人呢？我认为哈罗德·戈德温森赢得了一场惊人的胜利。这是英国人民历史上在这个阶段最伟大的胜利之一。我的意思是，绝对堪比阿尔弗雷德或阿特尔斯坦赢得的任何一场胜利，
won by Alfred or Athelstan, to have defeated a Norwegian army led by the most, arguably the most famous warrior in Northern Europe, in all Europe, to have killed him, to have won such a crushing victory, there is no chance the Norwegians will come back. I mean, Norway is out now. It is a great tribute to the potency of Anglo-Saxon arms. And to Harold Godwin's leadership, actually.
击败了一支由全欧洲、可以说整个北方欧洲最著名的勇士所率领的挪威军队，杀死了他，取得了如此压倒性的胜利，挪威人再无卷土重来的可能。我的意思是，挪威现在出局了。这对盎格鲁-撒克逊军队的战力是一个巨大的赞誉。实际上，这也是对哈罗德·戈德温森领导力的赞誉。
Absolutely. When you combine able leadership with the military resources of the Anglo-Saxon kingdom, Stamford Bridge is evidence that everything is fine, that it's ticking along. Well, I mean, Harold Godwinson can feel very, very pleased with himself. For a few days he remains in York to rest. You can imagine his overwhelming relief. He's had months of waiting, months of uncertainty, and he knows now for the time being, his kingdom is secure and his crown is safe.
绝对的。当你把有能力的领导力与盎格鲁-撒克逊王国的军事资源结合起来时，斯坦福桥就是一切安好、一切正常运转的证明。好吧，我的意思是，哈罗德·戈德温森可以为自己感到非常非常高兴。他在约克停留了几天休息。你可以想象他心中那种无法抑制的如释重负。他经历了几个月的等待，几个月的动荡，现在他知道目前来看，他的王国是安全的，他的王冠是稳固的。
And by now it is well into the autumn and people just don't sail in, you know, with huge expeditions in this kind of, this time of year. And then at the turn of October, a messenger arrives in York and when he's shown in to see Harold Goldwinson and he stammers out the words of the message, the blood drains from Harold's features because Tom, against all the odds, William of Normandy has landed at Pevensey and now for Harold and for the English, the road leads to Hastings and a final showdown. Unbelievable tension. I mean, who would not want to hear that episode right now, to be honest. And if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, the housecalls of our podcasters,
而现在已经是深秋了，人们在这个季节通常不会带着庞大的远征军乘船前来。接着，在10月初的时候，一个信使抵达了约克，当他被带去见哈罗德·戈德温森并结结巴巴说出信件内容时，哈罗德脸上的血色瞬间褪去，因为汤姆，顶着所有的不可能，诺曼底的威廉已经在佩文西登陆，现在对于哈罗德和英国人来说，通往黑斯廷斯和最终决战的道路已经铺就。难以置信的紧张感。我的说实话，谁不想现在就听这一集播客呢。如果你是“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员，也就是我们播客的听众访谈，
we like to think of them. You can. And if you're not, then you can sign up at therestishistory.com and join us for Slaughter at Sednlak Hill. And all that thrilling bombshell. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们喜欢这样称呼它们。你就可以。如果你不是，那么你可以在 therestishistory.com 上注册，加入我们，一起见证森德拉克山大屠杀。所有的这些令人惊叹的爆炸性新闻。再见。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。